Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und das hier ist Ausgabe 113,
und nachdem hier mal zwei Monate Sommerpausen, ähm, Sendepause war,
Sommerpause, Sendepause, Sommersendepause war, äh, sind wir wieder da,
nämlich ich und Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Denn wir müssen ja berichten, wir müssen ja euch erzählen und uns auch,
was eigentlich passiert ist in der Ukraine.
Es ist ganz interessant, dass wir auch im letzten Jahr zu diesem Zeitpunkt so
eine Pause gemacht haben und eigentlich auch eine ähnliche Phase überblickt haben,
nämlich eine Phase, wo zwar nicht nichts passiert ist,
Aber wo das Geschehen so homogen in gewisser Hinsicht war,
dass es eigentlich nie so richtig uns getriggert hat mit, oh man,
jetzt müssen wir aber mal ein Update liefern, weil es ist so viel passiert.
Es passieren zwar viele Dinge, im Wesentlichen wird einfach viel gekämpft,
aber es sind keine nennenswerten Wendepunkte eingetreten, sondern es war eher
eine Zeit der kontinuierlichen Vorgänge.
Bis dann so ein Söldner-Chef vom Himmel fiel und das passte dann jetzt sozusagen auch ganz gut,
weil wir ohnehin wieder zusammenkommen wollten und dementsprechend haben wir
uns hier zusammen gefunden, um für euch mal diese letzten zwei Monate zusammenzufassen.
Ja. Können wir eigentlich auch gleich loslegen, oder?
Ja.
Gut. Wir beginnen wie immer erstmal mit einer Nacherzählung dessen,
was sich so im Großen und Ganzen und natürlich im Spezifischen auch im Militärischen
getan hat, weil daran lässt sich natürlich leider diese Erzählung des Krieges
noch am besten aufreihen.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz einen Blick, wo wir bei der letzten Sendung stehen geblieben
sind, beziehungsweise was wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt aufgegriffen haben.
Das Ganze ist wie gesagt zwei Monate her, 27. Juni haben wir die Sendung veröffentlicht.
Ja und das war genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, nachdem dieser Wagner Aufstand stattgefunden hat,
dieser Marsch gegen Moskau, der dann jäh beendet wurde und in etwas unklaren Abkommen,
Friedensangeboten, Zugeständnissen der russischen Seite für Straffreiheit und
so weiter einen merkwürdigen Deal mit Weißrussland endete,
wo auch nie so ganz klar war, ob das, was jetzt so bekannt wurde,
auch in irgendeiner Form der Wahrheit entspricht, beziehungsweise wenn ja,
was das eigentlich genau bedeutet.
Also das war das eine und in gewisser Hinsicht hat diese Story auch jetzt erst
so Closure erhalten oder beginnt zumindest jetzt erstmal rund zu werden.
Und auf der anderen Seite waren wir an einem Punkt angelangt,
wo man sagen kann, jetzt hat die lange angekündigte und versprochene Gegenoffensive
der Ukraine im Süden des Landes ernsthaft begonnen.
Das war glaube ich so das was man festhalten konnte und jetzt zwei monate später
Kann man sagen die offensive hat angehalten findet die letzten zwei monate über
kontinuierlich statt und es ist ein.
Langsamer schmerzhafter aber trotzdem schrittweise voranschreitender prozess
an mehreren fronten der letzten Endes so in einem Zustand angekommen ist,
wo man davon sprechen kann, dass es jetzt an der Ukraine ist,
die russische Seite in ihren Fähigkeiten und Möglichkeiten zu widerstehen.
Abnutzen will, also dass die Ukraine, die Russen sozusagen so sehr in ihren
eigenen Krieg verwickeln will,
um ihnen dadurch Schaden zuzufügen, indem sie einfach nicht mehr gegenhalten können irgendwann.
Die Situation war ja nun so, dadurch, dass die ganzen Unterstützungszusagen
des Westens zwar schrittweise kamen,
aber eben langsam waren, und wir haben ja viel darüber gesprochen,
wie lange es gedauert hat, bis die Debatte von Luftabwehr auf Panzer auf anderes
Gerät umgeleitet wurde, bis wir dann irgendwann auch bei der Debatte um die
Flugzeuge angekommen sind,
die jetzt zwar noch nicht abgeschlossen ist, aber wo zumindest absehbar ist,
da reden wir auch noch heute nochmal drüber, wo absehbar ist,
dass auch das dann irgendwann stattfindet, aber es hat sich halt einfach alles ewig gezogen.
Es gab Länder, die haben einfach ewig gebraucht, dazu gehört natürlich Deutschland
vor allem, aber auch die USA, so ihre Zurückhaltung und hat sie teilweise auch immer noch.
Also die Unterstützung der Ukraine ist zwar da, sie ist auch umfangreich,
aber sie ist eben zu keinem Zeitpunkt so gnaden- und bedingungslos gewesen,
dass man sagen kann, okay, koste es was es wolle, jetzt schlagen wir zurück
mit allen Möglichkeiten, die wir haben.
Und das mögen politische Gründe gewesen sein,
das mögen liefertechnische, ausrüstungstechnische Gründe gewesen sein,
eine Vielzahl von Gründen, aber am Ende hatte die Ukraine einfach nicht das Material,
um früher zurückzuschlagen und das hatte einfach den Russen die Möglichkeit
gegeben, sich tief, tief einzugraben und gegen diesen tief eingegrabenen Zustand
geht der Kampf in den letzten zwei Monaten.
Also man kann sagen, die Unterstützung ist nach wie vor begrenzt und ich glaube,
man kann auch konstatieren, dass es nicht nur logistische Probleme oder Verfügbarkeitsprobleme sind,
sondern der Westen sitzt noch massiv auf Waffen und Waffensysteme.
Allein die Amerikaner haben 3000 Kampfpanzer auf Halde und liefern jetzt ein
paar Dutzend und das auch nur allmählich und so.
Also sie läuft irgendwie mit angezogener Handbremse plus dann völlig auch willkürliche,
aber schon etwas feige Vorgaben,
dass die Ukraine westliche Waffen,
also Raketensysteme irgendwie nicht gegen Russland proper oder gegen urrussisches Gebiet einsetzen darf,
sondern nur gegen Ziele auf eigenem Territorium,
während natürlich Russland frei ist, mit seinen Langstreckenwaffen und Raketen
die gesamte Ukraine mit Bombenterror zu überziehen.
Das alleine ist so ein Ding, wo man sagt, das ist super mutig vom Westen,
der Ukraine Waffen zu geben, aber bitte nicht auf die Russen oder nicht auf Russland abschießen.
Es ist schon ein bisschen zurückhaltend, der Westen, um das mal so zu formulieren.
Er hält im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Waffen zurück.
Das kann man glaube ich feststellen, die verfügbar wären.
Die verfügbar wären. Teilweise ist es auch ein schwieriger politischer Prozess
oder vielleicht ist es immer ein schwieriger politischer Prozess.
Ich meine man kann das natürlich jetzt den Regierungen einfach so vorwerfen,
da müssen wir nur nach Deutschland schauen, dann sehen wir halt was für eine
diffuse öffentliche Meinung auch teilweise herrscht.
Also ich merke das ja auch, wenn ich mit Freunden rede, die jetzt nicht so wie
wir täglich das Geschehen verfolgen und sich vielleicht auch zu Beginn des Krieges
nicht so sehr mit den Hintergründen auch auseinandergesetzt hat,
die uns ja in dem Sinne auch nicht so umfangreich bekannt waren.
Wenn ihr unsere ersten Sendungen verfolgt habt, da haben wir auch sehr viel
darüber geredet, was wir selber erst mal gelernt haben, über was überhaupt in
der Ukraine passiert ist in den letzten 10,
20, 30, 40 Jahren, was die Situation ist in Russland, alles für uns keine täglichen Themen.
So, wenn man das alles nicht gemacht hat, dann hast du es dann in der Gesellschaft
natürlich mit allgemeinen politischen Positionierungen zu tun.
Und die beziehen sich nicht so sehr auf das reale Geschehen,
sondern die haben halt mit grundsätzlichen Haltungen zu tun.
Und da kommt halt viel zusammen. In Deutschland halt diese Ost-West-Trennung, nicht?
Wir haben halt einen Osten, der eben über Jahrzehnte auch,
sagen wir mal, einen unmittelbaren russischen Bezug hat und das führt teilweise
zu Allianzen oder sagen wir mal,
zumindest mal zu anderen Sichtweisen, die einfach prinzipieller Natur sind,
wo man vielleicht sich das selber nicht so zugestehen will, dass jetzt irgendwie
Russland das böse Land ist.
Oder dass man auch aus so einem latenten Anti-Amerikanismus,
der in Deutschland ja auch sehr stark war und ist, eben auch dann wiederum nicht
das entsprechende Vertrauen für westliches Handeln ableitet.
Also diese gesamte Gemengelage, das sind natürlich reale politische Realitäten
und die werden aus Position der Regierung natürlich immer auch durch irgendeine
Opposition ausgenutzt.
Und Regierung ist ja auch tägliches Überleben, das gilt glaube ich besonders
für unsere aktuelle Regierung.
Und ja, die Bewertung, was dann quasi angemessene Schritte sind,
ohne sich selbst des Rückhaltes für die regierenden wichtigen Teile der Bevölkerung
sicher zu sein, die fällt da sehr unterschiedlich aus. Und dann...
Da sagt man halt so, ah ja nee, da können wir jetzt nicht weitergehen und dann
kommen halt diese ganzen floskelnden Phrasen mit Eskalationsangst etc.
Wobei angesichts dessen, was halt ne Ukraine betrifft, finde ich halt einfach
diesen Begriff der Eskalation mittlerweile vollkommen für unangemessen,
weil mal ehrlich, also was soll denn da bitte noch eskalieren,
das ist meiner Auffassung nach die totale Eskalation und man kann es halt eigentlich
nur noch besser machen, indem man Unterstützung bietet.
Na gut, aber findet nicht in dem Maße statt,
wie es vielleicht für uns angemessen erscheint,
real bedeutet es für die Ukraine, sie haben nicht diese Möglichkeiten und gerade
in den letzten Wochen gab es ja auch so Mediendiskussionen über,
oh die Ukraine, die Offensive, da verläuft ja alles nicht nach Plan.
Ja, womit so unterstützt, unterstellt wird, das hätte ja alles viel schneller
gehen müssen und wir wissen es ja sowieso besser.
Und dann kommt dann oft zum Beispiel auch so diese Spin mit,
ja ihr habt doch jetzt hier bei uns wie NATO-Taktiken gelernt,
ihr wollt doch jetzt hier kämpfen wie der Westen, warum macht der das denn dann nicht?
Wo man halt nur sagen kann, so ja, der Westen kämpft auch seine Taktiken unter
anderer Materialverfügbarkeit,
ja, also jede westliche Angriffs- und Offensivdoktrin basiert auf fundamentaler Lufthoheit.
Und davon ist die Ukraine halt weit, weit, weit entfernt, weil sie einfach die
Flugzeuge gar nicht dafür haben, um in irgendeiner Form eine Lufthoheit zu haben.
Die hat glücklicherweise auch Russland nicht, aber das ist schon etwas,
was eben die Situation konkret an der Front schwierig macht.
Haben wir auch letztes Mal schon drüber gesprochen.
Hubschrauberangriffe, aber auch Jetangriffe sind Teil des Problems,
zusätzlich zu den Minenfeldern und dagegen muss man sich dann halt erstmal durchsetzen.
Natürlich kann man irgendwelche Soldaten im Wald stehen haben,
die mit Manpads versuchen diese aufzuspüren und niederzuschießen,
aber teilweise schießen die einfach von großer Distanz, wo dann halt so ein
Manpad die Dinger gar nicht sieht.
Und das sind halt alles Schwierigkeiten, mit denen die Ukraine zu kämpfen hat.
Hilft die beste westliche Angriffstaktik und Disziplin nicht,
weil die einfach gar nicht trägt, weil die Voraussetzungen dafür überhaupt nicht gegeben sind.
Also das ist so die Ausgangssituation.
Jetzt kann man sich anschauen, was ist eigentlich tatsächlich passiert.
Und im Wesentlichen, kann man sagen, ist genau das passiert,
was wir auch letztes Mal schon berichtet haben.
Also es gab eine Serie von Angriffen und Vorstößen an verschiedenen Stellen der Front.
Und das teilt sich vielleicht ganz grob auch in zwei Teile.
Auf der einen Seite gibt es nämlich die Angriffe der Ukraine,
die im Wesentlichen in Saporischia, im südlichen Donbass und auch bei Kherson
ein bisschen stattfindet.
Also dort, wo der Vorstoß auch wirklich am wichtigsten ist, wo es gilt,
eben diese Landbrücke zwischen dem Osten und dem Westen des besetzten Gebietes zu durchbrechen.
Und dann gibt es aber auch noch im Osten, also oben bei Charkiv,
bei den von der Ukraine so heroisch zurückeroberten Gebieten,
gibt es wiederum Angriffe der Russen, die allerdings sehr überschaubar ausfallen.
Und eigentlich nur dazu dienen, die Ukraine auch in diesem Bereich in irgendeiner Form zu beschäftigen,
dort Truppen zu binden, um dann eben entsprechend Last aus dem südlichen Bereich
rauszunehmen. Das ist also insofern die...
Typische Methode, einfach mit Gegenangriffen den Gegner zu beschäftigen und das machen halt beide.
Aber schauen wir jetzt mal auf den eigentlichen Kernbereich.
Also es gab halt da oben im Westen bei Kupjansk, gab es Angriffe bei Kremina
von den Russen, das kann man eigentlich ignorieren.
Nach dem Angriff der Russen auf Bachmut und der Eroberung und man muss auch
sagen der Zerstörung von Bachmut, ist es der Ukraine gelungen,
um Bachmut herum im Norden und im Süden vorzustoßen.
Das beißt sich gerade auch ein bisschen fest. Hier kann man aber auch sagen,
dass es wahrscheinlich eher die Ukraine ist, die Russland beschäftigt,
weil sie Bachmut um jeden Preis verteidigen müssen, weil das für sie so ein Propagandading ist.
Das heißt, da schmeißt jetzt die Ukraine aber auch nicht alles rein.
Der Fokus liegt an dieser Südfront.
Und diese Südfront zieht sich halt von dem alten Dnipro-Becken,
ich sag jetzt von dem alten Dnipro-Becken, weil es halt mittlerweile alles sehr verlandet dadurch,
dass ja der Nowaka-Kofka-Staudamm gesprengt worden ist und ich hab jetzt keine
aktuellen Satellitenbilder im Kopf, aber der Fluss findet sozusagen zu seinem
alten Flussbett wieder zurück und die Wasserausdehnung ist halt dort sehr gering geworden.
Aber dort, wo eben dieses Becken ist, man kann ja diesen Bereich,
der jetzt nicht mehr überflutet ist, nicht nutzen, weil er noch viel zu matschig ist.
Also dort in Saporizia, nach Westen, rüber bis in den Donbass,
das ist so eigentlich der Bereich, wo es um die Wurst geht.
Und konkret geht es um die Wurst im Wesentlichen in zwei Gebieten.
Das eine Gebiet ist das Gebiet, um die Stadt umzubringen.
Veseli, na. Velika Novoselka meinst du?
Genau, Velika Novoselka. Dort sind eigentlich die ersten Vorstöße so richtig nennenswert gewesen.
Da gibt es so einen Fluss entlang dessen die Ukraine angegriffen hat,
Gebiete eingenommen hat, östlich und westlich des Flusses.
Und wo der Widerstand der Russen halt so jetzt über diese zwei Monate kontinuierlich
von Ort zu Ort gebrochen wurde.
Und der zweite Bereich ist dann eben weiter im Westen.
Das ist das Gebiet südlich von der Stadt Urikiv.
Und dort gab es auch signifikante Vorstöße, insbesondere in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Vor allem um den kleinen Ort Robotynä herum.
Und gut, das sind jetzt alles so Namen, die werden euch jetzt nicht viel sagen,
abgesehen davon, dass wenn man jetzt mal so in die Daily News reinschaut,
man eben diese Orte immer wieder mal hören wird, um das so verorten zu können.
Aber was passiert denn da eigentlich tatsächlich?
Man kann davon sprechen, dass die Russen jetzt in diesem Jahr,
wo sie Zeit hatten, eine Verteidigungslinie aufzubauen, so eine Struktur dort
geschaffen haben, die im Wesentlichen so aus drei Schichten besteht.
In der Berichterstattung hört man mal von ein oder von zwei oder von drei Verteidigungslinien.
Das ist so eine Frage der Interpretation. Ich würde jetzt mal von drei Verteidigungslinien sprechen.
Die erste ist eben die, die vor zwei Monaten betreten wurde.
Ein extrem vermienter Bereich.
Der halt im wesentlichen mit Schützengräben abgesichert ist von den Russen,
die sich dort tief eingegraben haben, die aber so auf breiter Front,
fast jede Tree-Line ist da also mit Schützengräben durchzogen und die Ukraine
hat sich jetzt eben mit verschiedenen Taktikwechseln Wege erarbeitet.
Diese Linie, die halt also vor allem durch diese Minen und den parallelen Artillerie-
und Hubschrauberbeschuss dort schwierig zu durchstreiten war,
sich da in irgendeiner Form vorzuarbeiten und das ist eigentlich so der große
Fortschritt der letzten zwei Wochen,
dass sie also diese Gebiete zumindest an diesen beiden Orten,
von denen ich gesprochen habe, also Velika, Nowosilka und südlich von Urikiv,
dass sie dort wirklich Fortschritte gemacht haben.
Fortschritte heißt, dass sie im Prinzip so 10, 12 Kilometer tief in russisch
besetztes Gebiet vorgedrungen sind.
Nicht nur tief, sondern auch breit.
Und ja, dabei diese sogenannte zweite Verteidigungslinie, diese Sorovikin-Linie
erreicht haben, wie es jetzt scheint.
Und das eben nicht nur an einem Punkt, sondern je nach Berichtslage gerade,
ich würde sagen mit so einer Kontaktfläche von 5 bis 10 Kilometern.
Das ist diese Surovikin-Linie, heißt die deshalb,
weil das eben die Verteidigungslinie ist, die aufgebaut wurde,
nachdem dieser General Surovikin, dieser General Armageddon,
von dem wir übrigens später noch hören, die Gesamtleitung übernommen hat,
die er mittlerweile nicht mehr hat.
Mittlerweile ist er in Ungnaden gefallen und verschwunden.
Aber diese Linie wird halt nach wie vor nach ihm benannt. Das sind diese Betonpyramiden,
die die Russen also großflächig auf langer, langer,
langer Strecke gepaart mit solchen tiefen Gräben davor, Also so panzerbreit
tiefe Gräben, sodass wenn da ein Panzer reinfährt, er einfach ins Loch fällt sozusagen.
So tiefe Gräben quer durch die Landschaft gezogen.
Und jetzt muss sich zeigen, wie es vorangeht. Wenn es so vorangeht wie bisher,
dann kann es noch einige Wochen dauern, bis wir hier neue Schritte sehen.
Auf der anderen Seite hat sich ja auch immer wieder gezeigt,
gibt es überraschende Vorstöße, weil in irgendeiner Form ein russischer Truppenteil
Schwächen gezeigt hat und die Ukrainer eine gute Taktik hatten.
Es gibt natürlich auch viel Gegenangriffe der Russen, es gibt auch immer wieder
Niederlagen und hohe Verluste.
Es ist alles in allem ein sehr blutiger Konflikt,
der da gerade ausgefochten wird, der aber durchaus die Möglichkeit jetzt in den Raum stellt,
dass es der Ukraine gelingt vielleicht zumindest an manchen Stellen auch diese
zweite Linie vielleicht noch nicht komplett zu durchbrechen,
aber durchlässig zu machen.
Und das Ganze erscheint natürlich, wenn man sich jetzt die Gesamtgröße dieses
Gebietes, was hier ja noch besetzt ist, anschaut, alles so Peanuts zu sein, ne?
Also wir reden von einer Gebietstiefe von der aktuellen Frontlinie bis zum Asowschen
Meer von ungefähr 80 bis 100 Kilometer,
je nachdem von wo nach wo man jetzt gerade misst.
Und die Fortschritte waren halt irgendwo bei 10 bis 12 Kilometern.
Und das hat zwei Monate gedauert. Da macht man natürlich schnell mal eine Hochrechnung
und sagt, naja, also wenn die zwei Monate für 10 Kilometer gebraucht haben und
100 Kilometer sind es noch bis zum Meer, dann dauert das ja ewig.
Ja, ganz so einfach ist es nicht. Wir blicken hier auf eine Landschaft,
wo jetzt Höhenlagen vor der Ukraine liegt, oder sie auch teilweise schon auf
diesen Höhen sind, und die enden dann aber auch 30, 40 Kilometer vor dem Wasser.
Das heißt, wenn es gelingt, diese Höhen zu, gar nicht mal komplett einzunehmen,
aber zu dominieren, dann wären wichtige Versorgungslinien der Russen unterbrochen,
unter anderem die Eisenbahnlinie, aber auch eben alle anderen wichtigen Verbindungsstraßen
unter direktem Beschuss von Heimatsystemen.
Und dann ist eigentlich eine Versorgung des Ostteils nur noch sehr,
sehr, sehr eingeschränkt möglich.
Sprich, ein Vorstoß um weitere 10 bis 20 Kilometer könnte hier schon entscheidende
Änderungen im Gesamtbild bringen.
Ja, also auch gesagt,
wenn man Progressbar oder so anbringen würde,
dann, wenn der auf die minimalste Entfernung guckt,
dann wäre er irgendwie bei 10 Prozent und wenn man jetzt rein auf die Fläche schaut,
so wie viel es jetzt allein ohne die Krim nur da unten zu befreien gilt,
dann ist das irgendwie einstellig in der Prozentzahl und aus der Ferne kaum zu erkennen,
also im Vergleich jetzt mit früheren Erfolgen, so bei Karkiv und Kärson,
aber gerade bei Kärson, hast du ja auch schon erwähnt, haben wir ja gesehen,
ging das im letzten Jahr auch erst mal lange, lange Zeit kaum voran.
Da gab es dann mal geringe Geländegewinne.
Aber ja, im Grunde genommen ist nicht viel passiert, bis die Russen sich dann
entschieden haben, Kershon einfach aufzugeben.
Dass sich das jetzt hier so wiederholen wird, davon kann man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ausgehen.
Aber, ja, wie du schon richtig sagst, man kann das auch jetzt nicht linear hochrechnen.
Positiv für die Ukraine ist, kann man glaube ich sagen, ist,
dass sie dort, wo sie die Initiative haben, auch gewisse kleine Erfolge vorweisen können.
Während es auf russischer Seite, die ja auch versuchen, eben vor allem im Norden
so möglichst weit weg da vom Süden Stress zu machen,
damit die Ukraine dort halt Kräfte hin verlegt, die dann da gebunden sind.
Aber diese russischen Versuche einer Offensive sind praktisch völlig fruchtlos.
Sie haben eigentlich so gut wie null vorzuweisen.
Und bei der Ukraine zumindest, wenn man nahe ran zoomt, sehen kann, dass es vorangeht.
Langsam, sehr langsam allerdings. Was auch schon sagt es daran,
liegt natürlich auch daran, dass wir dieses Thema, das Thema,
das Thema, das Thema des Klimaschutzes, das Thema des Klimaschutzes,
das Thema des Klimaschutzes,
Dass natürlich sich auch die Russen jetzt angepasst haben und vorbereitet haben
und dass beide Seiten jetzt auch mehr oder weniger auf ähnliche Art und Weise kämpfen,
viel mit Drohnen und dass das gesamte Gefechtsfeld unter Überwachung steht,
sodass für beide Seiten ist es schwierig, größere Truppenmengen zu konzentrieren.
Dazu kommt, dass die Russen auch ihre Artillerie auf feste Punkte eingerichtet haben,
dass sie wissen, wo sie hinschießen müssen, um den Vormarsch der ukrainischen
Truppen möglichst stark zu behindern.
Auf der anderen Seite, was wir auch gesehen haben in den letzten zwei Monaten,
viel war nach wie vor, dass die Ukraine sehr viele russische Artilleriesysteme
zerstört hat und Luftabwehrsysteme.
System. Also, dass sie sich halt darauf fokussieren,
vorzumarschieren, die russische Artillerie dazu zu bringen,
sie zu beschießen und dann mit Counter Battery Radar,
mit Anti-Artillerie Radar, dann die russischen Stellungen zu erfassen und dann
möglichst die Artillerie zu zerstören Und das ja zieht sich natürlich.
Genau. Also das mit der Artillerie hat vor allem zwei Vektoren.
Auf der einen Seite ist es klar, man will halt nicht beschossen werden.
Also Artillerie zerstören, insbesondere die Geräte zu zerstören.
Das ist natürlich gut, weil jedes Gerät, was nicht da ist, kann einen halt auch nicht mehr angreifen.
Andererseits, wir wissen, die Russen haben halt einfach viel Gerät.
Aber was halt auch noch wichtig ist, und da gehört ja dann auch noch die gezielte
Zerstörung von Waffenlagern auch noch mit dazu,
es geht auch der Ukraine darum, die Russen quasi unter Versorgungsstress zu
stellen, also dass sie halt durch die vielen Angriffe und durch,
diese permanente Beschäftigung und eben durch diesen Fokus der russischen Militärmaschine
überhaupt auf Artillerie,
dass sie in diesen Versorgungsstress kommen, weil sie müssen ja alles beliefern,
sie müssen überall Artilleriegranaten in riesigen Mengen da hinbringen.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit, das da hinzubringen, ist das mit einem LKW zu machen,
weil sie haben dort keine Bahnversorgung.
Und die Bahnversorgung, die ja letztlich die Stütze der russischen Logistik
überhaupt ist, naja, die findet halt derzeit nur über diese zwei Linien statt.
Und die eine wird halt gerade versucht die aufzutrennen und die andere über
die Krim ist halt durch verschiedene Angriffe auch stark unter Druck geraten.
Das hatten wir auch in der letzten Sendung schon erwähnt.
Es gab Angriffe auf diese nördlichen Krimbrücken, also die die Krim mit Rasson verbinden.
Da gibt es ja ganz im Westen, sagen wir mal eher eine Landverbindung,
also da ist richtig eine Straße ohne Brücken.
Das ist sozusagen aber auch der entfernteste Punkt und an dem östlichen Anschlussteil,
da sind diese Seenlandschaften und dort sind es tatsächlich zwei Brücken und
sowohl die Eisenbahnbrücke als auch die Straßenbrücken,
die dort sind, sind halt von der Ukraine stark beschossen worden und ich hab
jetzt nichts in der letzten Zeit gehört über entsprechende Reparaturmaßnahmen,
aber man kann davon ausgehen,
dass das eben diese Versorgungsfähigkeit der Truppen in Kherson und in Saborischia,
also der russischen Truppen, doch stark eingeschränkt hat.
Dazu kommt, dass es auch noch eine weitere Attacke oder zwei weitere Attacken
auf die Kerschbrücke gab.
Wir erinnern uns, die Kerchbrücke, die Brücke, die Russland und die Krim verbindet,
das gloriose Projekt von Putin, die Eisenbahn- und Straßenbrücke,
wo einst der LKW auf der Oberfläche der Brücke zur Sprengung gebracht wurde.
Dort gab es ja eine weitere Attacke, ich glaube das war nach unserer letzten
Sendung, durch diese neuen Wasserdrohnen.
Da sind also zwei dieser selbstfahrenden Boote oder ferngesteuerten Boote unter
die Brücke gefahren und sind unterhalb der Brücke detoniert und haben die Straßenbrücke
wiederum zum Einsturz gebracht, zumindest auf der einen Seite.
Es war ein bisschen unklar, ob auch die Bahn in irgendeiner Form betroffen war,
aber ein paar Wochen später gab es dann auch nochmal diverse Angriffe mit Raketen,
Wobei nie so ganz klar war, ob da die Raketen als solche abgeschossen wurden
oder ob es eine tatsächliche Detonation gab, aber die Kerchbrücke ist halt unter
Beschuss, die ist unter Druck, die läuft auf gar keinen Fall auf maximaler Kapazität.
Genauso eben die anderen Brücken und all das trägt eben dazu bei,
dass gleichzeitig der Druck, den die Ukrainer an dieser ganzen Südfront ausüben,
die Russen einfach in so einen Versorgungsstress bringt.
Der lässt sich von mir jetzt nicht quantifizieren, aber das ist sagen wir mal
die Methode, mit der sie hier vorgehen oder sagen wir mal, das ist das eigentliche
Ziel. Die Russen sozusagen.
An einen Punkt zu bringen, wo sie irgendwo an irgendeiner dieser Fronten nicht mehr in der Lage sind,
entsprechenden Widerstand zu organisieren, weil sie es logistisch nicht hinbekommen,
weil sie nicht mehr genug Truppen haben, weil sie sich bei ihrer Truppenverlagerung
vertun, an die falsche Stelle ihre Aufmerksamkeit geben, irgendetwas.
Und in dem Moment, wo der Ukraine auffällt, oh holla, da gibt es aber jetzt
gerade mal wirklich wenig Widerstand oder wir sehen da wenig Lieferungen oder
was auch immer deren Indikatoren dafür sind, dann können sie halt dann auch
entsprechend schnell vorstoßen.
Und das sieht man so im kleinen auch schon geschehen, gerade
in den letzten zwei Wochen ist also die Einnahme da von Robotone ist halt so
der Erfolg der Wochen davor gewesen und jetzt husch husch husch geht's auf einmal
wieder ganz schnell und man biegt gerade um diese Ortschaft herum und ist halt
wie vorhin schon erwähnt jetzt an dieser Surovikien Linie angekommen.
Also es kann halt sein, dass nachdem es sehr lange gedauert hat,
um überhaupt ein paar Fortschritte zu machen und man so denkt so,
ja bei euch passiert ja gar nichts, dass es dann auf einmal wieder ganz schnell geht.
Und um dann gleich das mit dem Progress Bar zu machen, ihr kennt ja,
wie das ist mit dem Progress Bar auf dem Computer, wenn man so eine Datei kopiert,
dann geht's dann erstmal so eine Viertelstunde lang, passiert fast gar nichts
und so die letzte Hälfte macht's dann einfach, und der Progress Bar rennt auf 100 Prozent.
Und genau so ähnlich verhält sich das mit manchen dieser Angriffe,
weil in dem Moment, wo der Widerstand dann erstmal gebrochen ist und eine Stellung
auch komplett überrannt wird, dann, das haben wir ja zum Beispiel par excellence
in dieser Offensive in Rakiv gesehen,
Dann muss sich halt der Feind auch erstmal sammeln. Das Problem hier ist,
Russland hatte zu viel Zeit, diese Verteidigungsstellen aufzubauen.
Und natürlich sind gerade die wichtigen Ziele, die jetzt eigentlich vor der
Ukraine liegen, also das ist ja gar nicht mal das Erreichen des Meeres,
ist nicht der Punkt, sondern es ist eigentlich das Erreichen von Tokmak.
Weil wenn Tokmak fällt oder von den Russen nicht mehr korrekt genutzt werden kann,
dann ist sozusagen die Eisenbahnverbindung im Eimer und damit bricht sozusagen
das ganze logistische Grundgerüst für die Versorgung der aktuellen Front ein.
Und derzeit sind sie davon mal zwanzig Kilometer entfernt.
Natürlich ist Tokmak umstellt mit weiteren Suruvikien, Pyramiden,
Gedenklinien und Schützengräben und alles.
Aber da das auch ihr eigener Bereich ist,
ihr eigener, sagen wir mal die Zone von der sie irgendwie ausschwärmen,
ist das halt nicht ansatzweise so stark vermint wie das jetzt mit diesem ersten Frontabschnitt war.
Also es ist schwer einzuschätzen, aber sehr weit weg sind die Ukrainer nicht
mehr und es wird in zunehmendem Maße schwierig für die Russen hier in irgendeiner Form zu verteidigen.
Und das Ganze auch unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass bestenfalls 25 Prozent der
verfügbaren Truppen der Ukraine derzeit wirklich im Einsatz sind.
Das Allermeiste liegt noch im Hinterland und wartet auf den Moment,
wo sie in irgendeiner Form sagen können, hier bricht jetzt gerade der russische
Widerstand zusammen, jetzt alle rein da und wir brechen jetzt hier komplett durch.
Wobei aktuell muss man konstatieren, dass den Russen noch nicht ihre Munition ausgegangen ist.
Klar gibt es immer wieder auch Meldungen, dass die Versorgungslage knapp ist
und einzelne Truppen, die berichten, dass sie schlecht ausgerüstet sind und
zu wenig Munition haben.
Aber so, wenn man sich anschaut, zum Beispiel auf Live-UA-Map,
wo die ganzen Meldungen von irgendwelchen Beschuss und Explosionen und so jeweils
verortet werden, dann sieht man dort.
Überwiegend Meldungen, die von russischem Artilleriebeschuss auf ukrainische Seite reden,
an dutzenden von Stellen jeden Tag, sodass man davon ausgehen kann,
dass die Russen nach wie vor jeden Tag tausende von Granaten auf die Ukrainer anziehen.
Allerdings hat sich vermutlich gegenüber von vor einem Jahr die Feuerrate eher angeglichen.
Also die Übermacht der russischen Artillerie, also die zahlenmäßige zumindest
Überlegenheit hat sich reduziert und es sieht so aus,
dass sie jetzt so langsam ungefähr Parität erreichen,
was so schwere Waffen angeht,
aber ja, Anzeichen dafür,
dass den Russen wirklich die Munition oder die Waffen wirklich ausgehen,
so muss man sagen, gibt es nicht auf, wenn man sich die gesamte Frontsituation
betrachtet, würde ich sagen, aus den Meldungen heraus.
So stellt sich das sicherlich dar, aber es ist halt so, in dem Moment,
wo es knapp wird, dann merkst du es halt auch schnell.
Also es ist halt jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie das linear runter geht
und du sagen kannst, oh ja jetzt sind wir nur noch bei 40 Prozent,
jetzt sind wir noch bei 30 Prozent, sondern irgendwann kollabiert das System halt komplett.
Wobei natürlich das dann eher auch zurückgeht, weil gut, sie nur im äußersten
Notfall irgendwie alles verschießen, was sie haben.
Sondern normalerweise dann, wenn sie merken, dass die Vorräte knapper werden,
wird halt mehr gehaushaltet.
Das heißt, man erkennt das dann schon im Vorfeld dann an einem Rückgang einfach der Feuerrate.
Weil mehr zurückgehalten wird und man kann diesen Rückgang,
Also ein Rückgang ist da, aber jetzt nicht so spektakulär, dass man jetzt sagen
kann, okay, die Russen haben nix mehr.
Ich sag auch nur, das ist die Strategie, die sich abzeichnet,
die die Ukraine verfolgt.
Sie sind halt nicht am Ziel, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, Teil der Gesamtstrategie.
Die Russen auf breiter Front beschäftigen, immer wieder überall Probings machen,
schauen, wo man Vorstöße machen kann, aber dann eben schon konkret bestimmte
Ziele in Angriff nehmen.
Und sicherlich ist eben der Angriff auf Tokmak das heißeste Ding,
weil das hat ja dann auch noch andere Konsequenzen.
Derzeit sieht es zum Beispiel so aus, dass durch diesen Vorstoß Richtung Tokmak
die Russen andere Truppenteile aus anderen Bereichen dorthin verlagern.
Und Es gibt eine Menge Berichte, wonach das so mit der Versorgung von Personal
schon eine etwas dünnere Geschichte wird.
Also vielleicht mag die Artillerie noch was zu feuern haben,
aber in Form von Kampfkraft durch Leute, die halbwegs ausgeruht sind oder gar
eine Rotation von Kampftruppen kann nicht so richtig die Rede sein.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein Ding, viele Truppenverlagerungen bedeuten auch
immer wieder Truppenkonzentrationen, die, wenn sie ausgeguckt werden,
natürlich auch ein wunderbares Angriffsziel sind für die Ukraine.
Alles konzentriert sich jetzt aber gerade um Robotini herum.
Unter anderem werden halt auch Truppen aus Rhaeson abgezogen.
Und das zeigt sich dann eben auch schon, dass dort andere Fortschritte möglich sind.
Jetzt ist Rhaeson, also wir reden jetzt hier vor allem von den beiden Teilen
Rhaesons, die durch den Neppar getrennt sind.
Also die Stadt Rhaeson liegt ja nördlich des Flusses Und eben südlich davon
sind die russischen Stellungen. Aber die sind halt nicht besonders ausgeprägt.
Und es gab jetzt zum Beispiel den Fall, dass in diesem kleinen Ort Kosatschi-Laheri,
also die Ukraine, mit so Landetruppen gelandet sind, also jetzt mit kleinen
Booten, voraussichtlich.
Und dort geschafft haben wirklich so ein komplettes Dorf für eine Weile aufzumischen,
weil die Russen einfach echte Probleme hatten, diesen Bereich in irgendeiner Form abzusichern.
Bis sie dann halt alles da wieder hingeschickt haben, das hat dann irgendwie
eine Woche gedauert, dann haben sich die Ukrainer auch schnell wieder verpisst
und dann den Druck auf eine andere Stelle wieder hochgehalten.
Und das wird natürlich jetzt auch immer einfacher werden, umso mehr sich die
Russen auf die Verteidigung von bestimmten Bereichen konzentrieren müssen,
die für sie einfach essentiell sind. Und der Bereich im Togmark ist essentiell.
Sie können sich jetzt nicht erlauben, Togmark zu verlieren. Wenn sie Tokmak
verlieren, ist im Prinzip meiner Meinung nach der Anfang vom Ende in Sicht,
also dieser Landbrücke sozusagen.
Und es verhält sich auch noch mit zwei, drei anderen Bereichen ähnlich und die
Russen wissen halt nicht, wo die Ukraine als nächstes zuschlagen wird.
Also, ich hab grad auch noch mal geguckt, was denn da so bei Robotüne auf russischer
Seite der Ukraine entgegen steht und das sind hier schon haufenweise Regimenter,
also ich würde sagen, das sind so geschätzt gut 30.000 Soldaten, die.
Dort jetzt den Vormarsch Richtung Togmak gerade versuchen aufzuhalten.
Das ist schon eine signifikante Truppenkonzentration.
Es mehr als so manches Land überhaupt an Soldaten hat, die da jetzt gerade konzentriert
sind auf russischer Seite.
Und eine ähnliche Anzahl, wie wir sagen, auch bei Staromaisk,
während wir ansonsten entlang des Rests der Front,
so wie es aussieht, eher ein Zehntel bis Zwanzigstel nur an Soldaten haben,
die den Rest der Front verteidigen.
Das heißt, ich sehe so alle 20 Kilometer irgendwie ein Bataillon,
während um Robot Hühne die Bataillone dicht an dicht quasi stehen,
so alle sind nicht pro Kilometer Frontlinie irgendwie ein Bataillon.
So sehe ich das gerade.
Ja, vielleicht mal ein bisschen was zu der Technik, die dort zum Einsatz kommt.
Also was ganz klar ist, das hat sich ja schon am Anfang des Krieges abgezeichnet,
aber mittlerweile ist es das Ding, es ist halt ein Drohnenkrieg.
Also diese ganze Frontlinie ist ein permanenter Battle von Drohnen.
Und nachdem die Ukraine hier lange, lange Zeit einen großen Vorteil hatte,
haben offensichtlich jetzt die Russen von den Chinesen auch größere Lieferungen
bekommen und setzen auch selber eine ganze Menge Drohnen ein.
Und das tun sie halt wie die Ukraine auf zwei Arten.
Die eine Art ist Überwachungsdrohnen, Kamera, Realtime Video etc.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass sozusagen permanent dieser gesamte Frontbereich
von beiden Seiten mit Drohnen überwacht wird,
die sich versuchen natürlich auch ihre Drohnen gegenseitig abzuschießen,
wenn sie die sehen, aber vor allem halt einfach alles unter Beobachtung haben
und dann entsprechend auskundschaften und ihre Artillerie drauf lenken.
Da hat die Ukraine natürlich den Vorteil, dass sie die sehr viel genaueren Zielsysteme
haben, also mit High Mass und auch mit ihrer besseren Artilleriebestückung können
sie also, wenn, dann auch genauer.
Ziele angreifen, wenn sie den dann erst mal erforscht haben.
Das zweite sind natürlich diese Kamikaze-Drohnen, also das machen auch die Russen,
die haben ja da diese eigenen Kamikaze-Drohnen, diese Lancet-Drohnen,
die zwar kein besonderer, Also die jetzt nicht von der Explosionskraft her nicht
riesig sind und eine relativ hohe Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit für gepanzerte Fahrzeuge hat,
aber wenn du es halt in Radar und sowas reinschießt, dann ist natürlich dann
die Technik auch schnell im Eimer.
Und genauso geht es auf ukrainischer Seite natürlich auch mit der Aufrüstung voran.
Und man hat ohnehin das Gefühl, dass Drohnen so ein bisschen der Schwerpunkt
auch der ukrainischen Militärproduktion geworden sind.
Also die produzieren jetzt nicht nur selber Artilleriegeschosse,
sondern sie produzieren vor allem auch moderne Drohnen.
Und wir hatten das mit diesen Drohnen zu Wasser, also diese selbstfahrenden
oder ferngelenkten Boote mit riesigen Explosionsmengen,
die halt unter anderem die Kerchbrücke deformiert haben, die andere Schiffe
angreifen können. Also das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Aber es gibt ja auch Drohnenangriffe auf russischem Gebiet bis hin zu Moskau.
Das ist ja auch so eine Neuerung der letzten zwei Monate, dass es halt mehrere
sehr erfolgreiche Drohnenangriffe gab auf Moskau.
Mittlerweile lässt sich gar nicht mehr genau sagen, was für Drohnen eigentlich
im Einzelnen so zum Einsatz kommen, weil es halt teilweise umgebaute alte Drohnen
sind, die wieder reaktiviert wurden, die noch mit anderer Technik ausgestattet wurden.
Oder eben auch schon komplette neue Entwicklungen sind, die man auch gar nicht
kennt, weil sozusagen die Ukrainer damit jetzt auch nicht groß hausieren gehen,
was sie in ihren eigenen Militärlabs zu entwickeln und zu produzieren in der Lage sind.
Das bestimmt das Bild. Das heißt die Ukraine macht Angriffe auf,
man kann sagen auf militärische Ziele des administrativen Bereichs.
Es gab ja in Moskau verschiedene Anflüge auf Gebäude des Verteidigungsministeriums
oder des FSB oder was auch sonst noch im Ziel lag.
Und die Russen konnten das teilweise durch direkte Abschüsse kontern oder eben
durch Electronic Warfare,
also durch entsprechende Bestrahlung dieser Drohnen,
um ihre Navigationssysteme außer Gefecht zu setzen oder eben auch die ganze
Elektronik selbst, sodass diese Drohnen dann teilweise in andere Hochhäuser
nearby reingestürzt sind und da natürlich potenziell auch zivile Opfer erzeugt haben können.
Aber diese ganze Drohnengeschichte ist einfach so das überhängende technische
Thema derzeit, finde ich.
Ja, definitiv. Und bis hin sogar, als ich gesehen habe, die Ukrainer haben eine
Art von Drohne, die aus Pappe gebaut wird.
Das ist ja eine australische Drohne ist das.
So, die scheinen auch tatsächlich ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Die können vor allem, obwohl sie aus Pappe gebaut sind und günstig sind,
können sie irgendwie angeblich 45 Kilo transportieren. Das hat mich sehr überrascht.
Also auf jeden Fall billig zu bauen mit Pappe.
Ich meine, du hast immer noch Motor und ganzen Komponenten,
aber ja, aus Pappe hat halt ein bisschen auch den Vorteil, dass die vom Radar
her dann ganz schlecht erfasst werden können, nur mit Radar.
Und dass die Russen dann vor allen Dingen auch super teure Flugabwehrraketen
und so verschwenden müssen, um dann diese Pappdrohnen abzuschießen.
Aber letztlich hat sich die Art und Weise, wie beide Seiten kämpfen,
aneinander angenähert, kann man feststellen. die Unterschiede.
Sind jetzt nicht mehr so gravierend oder es ist nicht mehr so asymmetrisch,
wie es vor einem Jahr noch war,
sondern beide Seiten haben Probleme,
Truppen, Panzer und so weiter zu konzentrieren in Gegenden,
weil sobald irgendwo eine Truppenkonzentration in Frontnähe oder teilweise sogar weiter weg erfolgt,
generiert man damit ein attraktives Ziel und zieht halt Feuer an.
Und das gilt aber für beide Seiten, weshalb wir auch nicht so jetzt die großen Panzerschlachten mit,
ich weiß nicht, 50, 100, 200 Panzern oder so,
die da auf freiem Feld aufeinandertreffen, weil du diese Menge an Panzern gar
nicht konzentrieren kannst mehr heutzutage,
was die Russen ja am Anfang getan haben und was dann zu krassen Verlusten geführt
hat und das machen sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Und ja, genauso eben massive Artillerieangriffe, so wie sie am Anfang noch der
Fall waren mit weiß ich nicht, 10, 20, 30 Batterien, die da irgendwo ihre volle Barrage abgeben.
Das kann sich keine Seite so richtig mehr leisten.
Jetzt ist mehr Shoot and Scoot angesagt. Also man fährt irgendwo hin,
feuert ein paar Schuss ab und sieht zu, dass man so schnell wie möglich ja,
den Platz verlässt, weil dann man zu befürchten hat, dass da dann die Gegenseite einen beschießt.
Und ja, das gilt jetzt eben zunehmend auch für die Ukrainer.
Dass die Russen eben eine gute Vorstellung davon haben, wo die ihre Truppen konzentrieren.
Trotzdem, und da lohnt es nochmal einen Blick auf die Krim-Situationen im Speziellen
zu machen, die Ukraine ist in der Lage, die Russen immer wieder zu überraschen.
Unter anderem auch mit Drohnenangriffen, aber nicht nur. Also gerade so Sevastopol,
der große Militärhafen, als auch einige andere Ziele in der Krim konnten also
erfolgreich von solchen Drohnenangriffen angegriffen werden und oft sind es
halt auch nur so Schwärme,
die immer wieder in anderen Anflugrichtungen losfliegen,
um dann einfach mal zu proben, okay wo habt ihr denn eure Verteidigungssysteme
und dann werden diese Verteidigungssysteme teilweise eben auch von Drohnen sehr
erfolgreich zerstört, wie vor kurzem.
Und dann in einem besonderen Stunt gab es jetzt offenbar sogar eine Landung
von Spezialtruppen auf der Krim.
Man mag es gar nicht glauben. Ja also ich frage mich immer noch woher die gekommen
sind. Ob die da von dieser Insel gekommen sind. Hier von der Schlangeninsel.
Oder wie sie das bewerkstelligt haben, auf jeden Fall sind sie da mit Spezialbooten gelandet,
haben mal kurz so einen russischen Kommandopost geradet, die sich wohl sehr
gewundert haben, woher jetzt die Ukrainer kommen und bevor die dann alle wieder
zurückschlagen konnten, waren sie schon wieder in ihren Booten und schon wieder weg.
Das war mir ein bisschen unklar, was so der militärische Nutzen war,
aber so rein psychologisch dürfte das auf jeden Fall gesessen haben. BK'IN DR.
Ich meine, das wären auch Luftabwehrstellungen oder Radarstellungen,
genau. Ich glaube, die haben Radarstellungen zerstört, die auf das Schwarze Meer gerichtet waren.
Dort Küstenradars, die das Schwarze Meer überwachen und die sollen wohl Ziel
gewesen sein, dieses Raids.
SPRACHER 1 Okay, kann gut sein. Und der ganze Angriff auch mit diesen wasserbasierten
Drohnen gilt ja jetzt auch nicht
nur der Brücke, sondern eben auch den Schiffen, habe ich schon erwähnt.
Und hier kommt ja jetzt nochmal ein anderer Punkt mit rein, nämlich das Auslaufen
des Abkommens über Getreidelieferung der Ukraine an den Rest der Welt.
Da gab es ein Datum, jetzt habe ich es gerade nicht parat, ich glaube vor einem
Monat war das, Ende Juli, lief glaube ich dieses Abkommen aus und ist dann halt
von den Russen nicht verlängert worden.
Und haben natürlich jetzt ganz protzig gesagt, so okay,
alles klar, jetzt darf hier gar nichts mehr geliefert werden und haben natürlich
dann auch noch, weil es Russen sind, auch noch die Getreidesilos und Hafenanlagen
in Odessa und anderen Häfen im Schwarzen Meer angegriffen, teilweise zerstört.
Um sozusagen auch generell zu verunmöglichen, dass halt Getreidelieferungen
von der Ukraine über das Wasser noch durchgeführt werden können.
Es ist nicht alles zerstört und sicherlich ist das eine oder andere auch schon
wieder repariert worden. Zuletzt gab es jetzt diese Angriffe nicht mehr.
Aber die Ukraine hat auch zurückgeschlagen unter anderem auch mit einem Drohnenangriff
auf ein russisches Militärschiff im Hafen von Novorossiysk.
Und das ist der andere große Militärhafen, der halt wirklich auf russischem
Mainland liegt, nicht wie Sevastopol auf der Krim.
Und das Schiff hatte dann Schlagseite, ist nicht untergegangen und musste da
angedockt und gestützt werden.
Also auch das ist der Ukraine möglich gewesen so einen Angriff zu machen.
Und das ist von der russischen, äh von der ukrainischen Coastline ist dieser
Hafen, naja, ungefähr, ähm, naja, 700 Kilometer entfernt.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also sie haben es geschafft,
eine Drohne 700 Kilometer weit durch das schwarze Meer unbemerkt zu bringen,
um dann in diesen Militärhafen reinzurücken und dort irgendwie eines ihrer Schiffe platt zu machen.
Und das ist halt jetzt gerade so das Bedrohungsszenario. Die Russen haben im
Prinzip gesagt so naja also jetzt ist hier alles, alles ist offen wir betrachten
jetzt mal jedes Schiff was hier fährt als ein potenzielles Lieferschiff für Militärgüter.
Sie haben jetzt letzte Woche auch mal mit einer Special Ops,
haben sie mal ein Schiff angehalten, niemanden umgebracht.
Ein türkisches, genau. Und da halt so ein bisschen mal geguckt,
nichts gefunden, sind sie wieder abgedüst. Das war halt so eine Showaktion,
so nach dem Motto, probiert es gar nicht erst, sonst gehen wir euch hier im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes aufs Dach.
Sehr viel mehr kam da jetzt nicht. Auf der anderen Seite werden sich die russischen
Militärschiffe auch hüten,
zu nah an diese Küste zu geraten, weil umso näher sie der ukrainischen Küste kommen,
umso höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie von irgendeinem dieser Drohnen zu
Wasser oder eben auch zu Luft oder eben von Storm Shadow oder ähnlichen Raketen platt gemacht werden.
Also es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, ob die Strategie der Russen ihn hier wirklich
genutzt hat oder nicht, auf jeden Fall ist eine gewisse Verunsicherung da.
Also bemerkenswert ist halt, dass vielfach gesagt wurde,
dass die Ukraine ohne wirklich eine Marine,
eine Kriegsmarine zu haben,
ja, den Russen
eigentlich große Teile des Schwarzen
Meers strittig macht und
dass die russische Marine einfach nicht gut aussieht im Schwarzen Meer und nicht
wirklich entscheidende Beiträge gerade leistet im Vergleich zu dem,
was sie wahrscheinlich kostet und an Ressourcen verschlinkt und was man auch
an Verlusten zu verzeichnen hatte.
Das Bedrohungsszenario ist auch nicht ganz klar. Wenn sie jetzt also wirklich,
angenommen Russland würde jetzt so ein Getreidefrachter versenken.
Der gehört dann unter Umständen mal nicht der Ukraine.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Sondern irgendeinem Land. Sagen wir mal einen türkischen Frachter.
Dann hätten sie halt so ein NATO Schiff quasi angegriffen.
Das werden sie nicht tun, weil das wäre sehr dumm.
Da hatten wir ja dann schon die Variante, dass sie,
einfach mit U-Booten Minen vor dem Schiff treiben lassen und dann sagen, ja, war halt eine Mine.
So dass das sozusagen die Art und Weise ist, wie sie dann solche Frachtschiffe
angreifen und dann sagen, war eine ukrainische Mine.
T. Könnten sie machen, aber haben sie bisher so nicht getan.
Und weil das halt ein riskantes Spiel ist und vor allem dadurch,
dass jetzt die Ukraine im Gegenzug gesagt hat, Also wenn ihr jedes Schiff von
uns als potenzielle Beteiligung am Krieg anseht, dann machen wir das mit euren Schiffen auch.
Und ihre Schiffe müssen halt auch irgendwie durchs Schwarze Meer fahren und
müssen auch versichert werden.
Und es ist natürlich für Russland jetzt auch sehr schwierig,
entsprechende Versicherungen zu bekommen,
wenn diese Schiffe durch ein Kriegsgebiet fahren, wo halt irgendwie wasserbasierte
Drohnen der Ukraine unterwegs sind, die schon gezeigt haben,
was sie können und vollkommen klar ist, dass jetzt hier Feuer frei gilt.
Also deswegen, das ist das was ich meine mit, es ist gar nicht so klar,
dass das wirklich eine Maßnahme der Russen war, die ihnen jetzt geholfen hat.
Zumal sie ja vorher im Rahmen dieses Getreideabkommens, das war ja nicht nur
so ein, ach wir lassen euch mal machen.
Sondern das hat ja bedeutet, sie haben auch die ganzen Daten darüber bekommen,
welche Schiffe fahren da lang.
Also sie haben vorher eine totale Transparenz erhalten, darüber was eben tatsächlich
an Schiffsaktivität stattfindet.
Ich finde, dass sie vielleicht nicht auf die Schiffe draufschauen können,
aber sie waren zumindest insofern in Control, als dass sie diesen Überblick
bekamen, den haben sie jetzt eben komplett verloren.
Jetzt ein Mover, der ihnen groß weitergeholfen hat, wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Natürlich ist es für die Ukraine eine weitere Schwierigkeit Getreide zu exportieren
und muss teilweise auf andere Wege gehen.
Es gibt ja jetzt zum Beispiel eine Vereinbarung mit Kroatien,
deren Häfen zu benutzen, aber dann muss natürlich das ganze Zeug auch erstmal
im Zug dahin gefahren werden und das ist ein langer und schwieriger Weg.
Ja, naja, wenn man sich auf Marine Traffic mal anschaut,
wo denn da gerade aktuell Schiffe langfahren,
kann man sehen, dass schon eine große Konvois von Schiffen natürlich durch den Bosporus da,
ja, und durchs Schwarze Meer Richtung Russland,
auch bis dann durch die Meerenge von Kerch und Rostov-on-Don,
da sind schon gerade, ich sage so, 50 Schiffe irgendwie aktuell unterwegs.
Während die ukrainischen Häfen, da findet halt nichts statt,
aber dafür drängeln sich gerade die Schiffe vor Rumänien, also vor dem Norden da von Rumänien,
Sachen, die die Donau runterkommen, dann dann zu übernehmen und so.
Also aber jetzt selbst Odessa oder so oder generell ja ukrainische Häfen ist
jetzt gerade nicht viel zu sehen.
Da ist eine, vielleicht zwei, drei Schiffe kleinerer Art, die sich da in den
Häfen befinden und das war's. aber unterwegs ist da irgendwie nicht allzu viel.
Ja, eine Handvoll von Schiffen ist aber auch da. Aber das Gro,
sei mal, hält sich fern aus ukrainischen Gewässern.
Na gut, das stimmt natürlich nur so halb, weil an diesem Donauausfluss sind
ja auch ukrainische Häfen, also Ismail, Kenia und so weiter.
Du hast zwei, drei Häfen, die sind natürlich nicht so groß und nicht so wichtig,
wie die von Odessa und den anderen Häfen in der Nähe.
Aber es kann sehr gut sein, dass ein Großteil dieser Schiffe,
die sich dort bei der Donau drängen, sehr wohl auch ukrainische Fracht transportieren.
Jaja, das wird wohl der Fall sein, ja.
Gut, wissen wir alles nicht so ganz genau, aber die generelle Situation ist,
der Vertrag ist gekündigt,
die Russen haben entsprechende Drohgebärden schon durchgeführt,
aber inwiefern das jetzt für die eine oder die andere Partei mehr vom Nachteil
oder mehr zum Vorteil ist, ist derzeit noch total unklar.
Ja, womit machen wir weiter, vielleicht um das ganze mal abzurunden,
wir hatten ja beklagt, dass nicht genug Waffenlieferungen sind,
vielleicht nochmal nen Blick da drauf, was jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich beschlossen
wurde, bzw. derzeit unterwegs ist.
Und da gibt es einerseits den Blick auf die deutschen Waffenlieferungen.
Deutschland liefert nach wie vor eine ganze Menge Zeug. Was die Ukraine gerne
hätte sind diese Taurus Langstreckenraketen,
die vergleichbare Features haben zu diesen Storm Shadow oder Scalp Raketen der Briten und Franzosen,
also die über sehr lange Strecken fliegen können und die auch GPS unabhängig
sind, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe oder sein können.
Ja, die machen beide Terrain-Matching,
also über Höhenradar vergleichen halt das Höhenprofil, das Aktuelle,
und können darüber dann feststellen, wo sie sind.
Und haben halt auch wohl, also von den Taurus-Systemen habe ich nur gehört,
dass sie umfangreiche Software haben,
die ziemlich komplexe Angriffsmuster ermöglicht Und auch so,
dass die Dinger auch ausweichen und ja, wilde Manöver machen, um durchzukommen.
Und auch irgendwie verschiedene Endanflugsmodi, so je nachdem,
was für Ziele bekämpft werden,
können die dann entweder im Endanflug gehen sie dann entweder hoch,
um dann mehr oder weniger senkrecht von
oben zu treffen oder dann auch
gegen andere ziele können sie dann eher im tiefflug von
der seite angreifen gut deutschland hat jetzt auch nicht so super viele von
den dingern aber es würde schon einen unterschied machen denke ich aber ja man
kann sich halt nicht dazu durchringen bisher die Dinger zu liefern.
Ja dann haben sie zumindest die Möglichkeit an anderen Stellen zu helfen.
Wer noch etwas zurückhaltender ist bei Waffenlieferungen ist ja die Schweiz
wie man sich schon denken kann.
Warum? Ja wegen Neutralität und so weiter. Die haben da irgendwie relativ klare,
ja ich weiß nicht ob das Gesetz oder Verfassung ist was an der Stelle greift.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher so verfassungsmäßig wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall ist der politische Widerstand groß.
Wir hatten das schon bei der Lieferung der Gepard-Flak-Munition, war das schon ein Thema.
Und jetzt ist es halt auch so, dass in der Schweiz auch noch Leopard-1-Panzer
rumliegen, die die Schweiz eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich braucht und die die
Ukraine natürlich gerne gehabt hätte.
Aber die werden halt irgendwie nicht rausgerückt, weil ist ja Krieg und da wollen
sie ja nichts mit zu tun haben. Was geht das die Schweiz an?
Ist ja nicht unser Krieg.
Und jetzt allerdings gibt es wohl eine Kompromisslösung,
die dahingeht, gemacht wird, dass Griechenland auch noch Leopard 1 Panzer hat,
die er aber auch braucht eigentlich, oder zumindest nicht komplett hergeben will.
Und das jetzt sozusagen so eine Art Ringtausch wird. Das heißt die Schweizer
liefern diese 100 Panzer an Griechenland, die etwas besser ausgerüstet sind
als die Griechischen und die Griechen liefern ihre 100 Panzer wiederum an die Ukraine.
Wie schnell das gehen wird, wie lange das dauert, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich wieder viel zu lange, aber immerhin findet es statt und das ist
glaube ich etwas, was Deutschland vermittelt hat, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Zumal die ja dann ohnehin in diese Entscheidungsprozesse immer eingebunden sein
müssen als Herstellerland etc.
International gibt es vor allem Dänemark und die Niederlande die Druck machen.
Dort scheint die Unterstützung der Ukraine überhaupt gar kein Thema zu sein.
Beziehungsweise eine angenehme Gelegenheit das eigene Arsenal mal zu upgraden.
Denn von dort kommen ja vor allem die ganzen zugesagten F-16 Flugzeuge.
F-16 ist jetzt nicht das allerneueste Modell, aber auf jeden Fall ein sehr universell
einsetzbares Kampfflugzeug, was eben die Ukraine gerne hätte.
Es gibt da sehr viele, das ist sozusagen well supported, das funktioniert,
das kann man für alle möglichen Dinge verwenden und wäre also eine willkommene
Aufrüstung für die Ukraine, obwohl sie halt sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr davon bräuchten.
Also mal locker das 10 bis 20 fache von dem, was bisher zugesagt ist,
um wirklich eine funktionierende Luftabwehr im gesamten Land zu haben.
Nichtsdestotrotz, das was Dänemark und Niederlande abzugeben bereit sind,
ist nicht ohne, weil es handelt sich glaube ich weitgehend um den kompletten
Bestand an F-16 Flugzeugen, die natürlich nicht alle auf einmal rüber gehen,
sondern halt jetzt ersetzt werden durch F-35 Flugzeuge.
Sprich Dänemark und Niederlande aktualisieren ihren Flugpark und schmeißen dann
sozusagen die alten F-16 an die Ukraine raus. Ob da irgendwie noch Geld fließt
weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Aber das ist sozusagen der Level auf dem sich da andere europäische Länder tummeln.
Da kann allerdings Deutschland auch nicht viel machen, weil Deutschland hat keine F-16 Flugzeuge.
Da sind sie glaube ich auch sehr glücklich drüber gerade.
Dass sie in der Debatte nicht auch noch drin sind.
Ja und wir reden glaube ich perspektivisch von bis zu 100 Kampfflugzeugen, richtig?
Die jetzt zugesagt sind.
Ja, von denen die Rede ist.
Das ist die Größenordnung. Aber brauchen würden sie halt irgendwie sowas wie 1.500 bis 2.000.
Also um dieses riesige Gebiet gegen so einen Gegner auch wirklich effektiv abschirmen zu können.
Gut, damit beenden wir vielleicht auch mal so unseren militärischen Fokus.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen auf diesen Elefanten im Raum reden,
nämlich den Tod von Prigurschin, den Chef von PMC Wagner, dieser Private Military Corporation.
Die so viel Lärm und Aufhebens gemacht hat und die eben vor zweieinhalb Monaten
so einen Aufstand gewagt hat,
sich mal eben zack zack zack die Stadt Rostov am Don einverleibt hat,
also da sozusagen das Militär unter Kontrolle gebracht hat und dann mit einem
schnellen Move Richtung Moskau gezogen ist, mit einem großen Trupp auf dem Weg
dann auch noch mehrere Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber abgeschossen hat, UKW berichtete.
Und so dass sich halt Putin ordentlich in die Hosen geschissen hat und sie in
totaler Panik schon angefangen haben Autobahnen aufzureißen,
bis dann dieser Tross auf einmal zum Stillstand kam und es so ein Deal gab mit Lukaschenko,
dem Präsidenten Weißrusslands, Putin und irgendwie Prigoshin,
der ihm in irgendeiner Form Straffreiheit zusagte, wenn sie denn nach Weißrussland gehen.
Es war alles total unklar und ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass wir in der letzten
Sendung auch so ein bisschen ratlos waren, was das jetzt eigentlich alles zu
bedeuten hat, was davon eigentlich fake ist und was davon eigentlich wirklich
so tatsächlich passieren wird oder ob nicht die Dinge komplett anders sind.
Ja, also mir wurde im Übrigen auch noch von Russen bestätigt,
dass die auch den Eindruck hatten, dass Prigogine,
dass da sehr viel inszeniert ist und dass er schon als mögliche Putin-Alternative aufgebaut worden ist.
Das war also jetzt nicht nur etwas, also wir hatten das ja so ein bisschen als.
Verschwörungstheorie, das sagen wir KGB-Kräfte auf jeden Fall auch im KGB und
im russischen Sicherheitsapparat da lieber einen stärkeren Mann als Putin hätten im Kreml,
der dann ordentlich aufdreht, was den Krieg angeht, den Putin da zu zögerlich ist.
Außerdem kam noch die Nachricht, dass man auch in den USA Prigogine oder generell
im Westen Prigogine nicht gerne als Putin-Nachfolger sehen würde,
weil man befürchtete, dass der dann den Krieg auf jeden Fall teurer macht und
unberechenbarer ist und das alles gefährlicher wird.
Deswegen war man auch im Westen lieber Putin als Prigogine.
Das war sozusagen dort das Thema, während eben in Russland der Eindruck war,
da wird definitiv auch eine Alternative aufgebaut.
Auch wenn Prygogin immer betont haben soll, dass er mit Politik nichts am Hut hat.
Aber ja, das ist jetzt alles Geschichte, weil es so aussieht,
als sei Prigogine tatsächlich tot.
Am Anfang gab es ja erstmal ein bisschen Zweifel dran,
weil er auch vor Jahren schon mal bei einem Flugzeugabsturz ums Leben gekommen
sein soll, nur um dann drei Tage später lebend wieder aufzutauchen.
War man sich nicht sicher, ist das auch wieder so eine Nummer,
wo er fälschlich für tot erklärt wird.
Aber mittlerweile kann man glaube ich sagen, deutet alles darauf hin,
dass er tatsächlich tot ist.
Also wir sagen zu 99 mit 99 prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit und man weiß mal was passiert ist.
Wahrscheinlich werden es die meisten schon gehört haben, aber vielleicht so
ein paar Details noch dazu und zwar ja ist ein Flugzeug mit.
Sieben Wagner Führungsleuten abgestürzt plus drei Besatzungsmitglieder,
zwei Piloten und eine Stewardess.
Sind auch noch ums Leben gekommen und das Ganze ist passiert auf dem Weg,
also im Flug von Moskau nach Sankt Petersburg und ist ungefähr auf halber Strecke
abgestürzt, also sie ist um 14.53,
Uhr in Moskau gestartet und um 15.20 Uhr gecrasht, also so 27 Minuten nach dem Start.
War der Absturz.
Und bei der Maschine handelt es sich um eine Embraer Legacy 600. Das ist.
Ein brasilianisches Geschäftsflugzeug und hat so typischerweise 12-13 Sitze
bis zu 16 Maximal wiegt so 22,5 Tonnen das Ganze,
also ist schon ordentlicher Brocken und kann 2.400,
Kilo knapp Nutzlast befördern und hat aber eine ordentliche Reichweite, so 6.300,
Kilometer kann also nonstop knapp über den Atlantik fliegen und kostet so im
Schnitt 10 Millionen US-Dollar gebraucht im Moment.
Und der Betrieb kostet so zwei Millionen im Jahr, wenn man von 400 Flugstunden ausgeht.
Das vielleicht zu dem Flugzeug und Das Flugzeug ist offenbar in der Luft auseinandergebrochen.
Das ist relativ sicher, weil man die Wrackteile relativ weit verteilt gefunden
hat. Die linke Tragfläche unter anderem wurde drei Kilometer entfernt vom Rumpf gefunden.
Steht. Es ist relativ sicher, dass das Flugzeug in der Luft eben auseinandergebrochen ist.
Und ja, was das, aber da kommen wir gleich später nochmal nochmal dazu, zu den Ursachen.
Aber erstmal interessant vielleicht noch die Passagiere, das neben Evgeny Prigozhin
auch die Nummer zwei, der Wagner-Gründer, Dimitri Utkin, mit an Bord war.
Und die drittwichtigste Person wahrscheinlich war Valery Tchkalov.
Das ist der Leiter von Wagners Logistik, der auch Logistik involviert,
nicht nur Waren, sondern auch Geld.
Das heißt, das war auch jemand, der so ziemlich viel Geld bewegt hat und ziemlich viel an Waffenkäufen,
Transporten und so weiter organisiert hat,
aber wahrscheinlich auch wichtig fürs Afrika-Geschäft war,
wo man dann auch umgekehrt die Rohstoffe und das Gold und die Ölverkäufe Also
da war ja wohl alles drin verwickelt.
Also auch jemand, der einfach wichtig war für Wagner und für die gesamte Organisation.
Symetry Utkin muss man natürlich dazu sagen, das ist the original Wagner.
Also das ist der Typ, nachdem diese ganze Organisation benannt ist.
Wagner ist quasi sein Call-Sign, also quasi sein militärischer Nickname gewesen,
weil er halt einfach so ein Nazi ist. Der Typ ist ja auch irgendwie übersät
mit so Nazi-Tattoos etc.
Also so ein voll krasser, voll Nazi- und Hitler-Fan.
Und Wagner hat er sich halt genannt, weil halt Wagner der Lieblingskomponist von Hitler war. war.
Kretschmann Ja, also auch ein ganz schönes Früchtchen.
Und ja, also sicherlich beides, also Prygogine und Utkin kann man definitiv sagen,
dass durch ihr Ableben die Welt sicherlich keinen großen Verlust erlitten hat,
sondern tendenziell eher zu einem besseren Platz geworden ist.
Aber man weiß natürlich nie so genau, auch solche schlechten Leute können manchmal
Gutes bewirken unabsichtlich.
So deswegen, Realität ist halt kompliziert.
Also da wachsen immer noch genug Vollidioten nach. Also die ist jetzt zumindest nicht schade.
Ja, also ich trauere da jedenfalls nicht diese beiden.
Und ansonsten, ja, die anderen, zwei Leibwächter waren noch dabei und zwei weitere
Wagner-Veteranen und Offiziere und so,
also da ist ziemlich viel auf einen Schlag, ja, quasi von einem Enthauptungsschlag
reden, was so Wagner angeht.
Und ja, und wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist,
aber da kommen wir gleich noch, darauf zu sprechen,
hat offensichtlich dann auch keinerlei Skrupel, dann nochmal drei Unschuldige
mit umzubringen, nämlich die drei Besatzungsmitglieder, beiden Piloten und die Flugbegleiterin.
Was so ein bisschen auch über die Sitten in Russland aussagt.
Und wenn man jetzt fragt,
was sind jetzt die Ursachen dieses Absturzes, denke denke ich,
wenn man da so einen Entscheidungsbaum macht, ist dann die Frage erst mal Anschlag oder Unfall.
Weil wir hatten ja auch darüber berichtet immer wieder,
dass es so mit der Wartung westlicher Flugzeuge nicht so gut bestellt ist,
wobei in dem Fall das ja brasilianisch ist und Bricks und so insofern.
Aber so die Firma Embraer hat sich auch zu Wort gemeldet und meinte,
dass sie seit 2019 dieses spezielle Flugzeug nicht mehr gewartet haben.
Das heißt, sie haben gesagt, wir wissen nichts, wir haben nichts damit zu tun.
Und ja, was auch immer passiert ist, so liegt nicht an der Maschine und tatsächlich.
Ist es so, dass jetzt ein Unfall ist zwar jetzt noch nicht völlig ausgeschlossen,
aber eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und von was die ERJ-Reihe von von Embraer angeht, wurden irgendwie 1200 Maschinen gebaut.
Und da gab es zwar acht Totalverluste, aber keine Todesopfer.
Also bei diesen acht Beschädigungen von Flugzeugen gab es bisher keine Toten.
Also das hier war jetzt der erste Zwischenfall mit Todesopfern an Bord einer
Maschine der Embraer ERJ Familie und von den speziell von den Legacy 600.
Also die Privatmaschine wurden 300 gebaut und die Firma hat auch darauf hingewiesen,
dass es bisher keinen Unfall aufgrund mechanischer Probleme gegeben hat mit
irgendeiner dieser 300 Maschinen.
Also in anderen Worten, es ist ungewöhnlich, dass die einfach vom Himmel fallen
und auseinanderbrechen.
Insofern ist ein Unfall höchst unwahrscheinlich.
Alternative ist dann halt Anschlag und es wurde erst spekuliert,
dass das abgeschossen wurde von,
ja, mit Boden-Luft-Raketen, dass irgendwie, ja, die russische Luftwaffe potenziell
die Maschine abgeschossen hat.
Aber so, die flog auf jeden Fall in einer Flughöhe, wo sie mit Manpads nicht
erreichbar war. Also dafür flog sie zu hoch.
Das heißt, man hätte dann schon ein größeres Flugabwehrsystem nehmen müssen
und US-Geheimdienste haben sich dazu öffentlich geäußert und gesagt,
es gäbe keine Hinweise auf eine Rakete,
was ich deswegen für glaubwürdig halte, weil wenn es Hinweise gäbe auf eine Rakete,
die Urheberschaft auch relativ klar oder einfacher zuzuordnen,
weil in Russland, also da schießt man nicht so eben mitten im Land die Luftabwehr
auf irgendeine Maschine, die auch.
Ja, offen mit Transponder und ADS-B-Beacon und so, also konnte man auf Lightradar
24 sehen, sogar die Maschine.
Und also keine Hinweise auf eine Rakete und sie sprechen von einer internen
Explosion, die US-Geheimdienste.
Also wahrscheinlich, Klartext, wahrscheinlich war eine Bombe an Bord.
Das ist das, wie nach derzeitiger Informationslage es aussieht.
100%ig sicher kann man halt nicht sein.
Aber ja, es war eine Bombe. Das macht es jetzt aber dann wiederum eher schwieriger,
jetzt daraus konkrete Schlüsse auf den Urheber zu ziehen.
Wie gesagt, wäre es eine Rakete gewesen, wäre es ein bisschen einfacher.
Aber bei einer Bombe ist die Liste möglicher Täter sehr lang.
Könnte die Ukraine gewesen sein, CIA, afrikanische Potentaten,
irgendwelche Geschäftspartner oder auch Militärs, die sich an Prigogine auch rächen wollten.
Also gab es, also er hatte nicht nur Freunde im Militär, sondern auch Feinde.
Aber natürlich der offensichtlichste Hintermann ist derzeit Wladimir Putin.
Dass er, ja, also zumindest haben alle damit gerechnet, ja, seit, seit,
Putin gezwungen war, Klein beizugeben, dass er Mittel und Wege finden wird.
Ja, Prigogine für diesen Verrat, wie er das sieht, entsprechend zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen.
Und was das bei Putin bedeutet, weiß man ja so von Polonium über Nervengift,
über Fenster, mehreren Defenestrationen.
Wie wir schon im Titel der letzten Sendung zitierten, die Abteilung für Infarkte und Defenestration.
Genau, also das hat sich abgezeichnet. BK'IN DR.
MERKEL. Ja, und insofern, ja, kann man sagen, zu 90 Prozent steckt irgendwie Putin dahinter.
Aber, ja, wirklich beweisen und sicher sein kann man halt bei Russland irgendwie nie.
Aber es ist, ja, es ist ein Mafiastaat auf jeden Fall.
Wo der von,
organisierten Kriminellen geleitet wird, die dann entsprechend auch handeln
und sich gegenseitig umbringen.
So sieht das aus.
Außer Putin scheint da auch niemand wirklich sicher zu sein.
Ne, da ist niemand sicher und das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Botschaft
hier. Auf der anderen Seite, geh mal, also, ich hab bisschen Schwierigkeiten
damit zu sagen, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es Putin war.
Vielleicht verteilen wir mal so ein paar Wahrscheinlichkeiten.
Also all diese ganzen Optionen,
die du genannt hast, mit Ausnahme des Unfalls, was dann doch eher sehr unwahrscheinlich ist,
hat alles so, sagen wir mal so eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit,
alles könnte so sagen wir mal so potenziell so eine zweistellige Prozentszahl
Wahrscheinlichkeit erreichen.
Ja, das Gefühl sagt einem so ein bisschen, es gibt halt einen offensichtlichen
Profiteur dahingehend,
als dass eben Putin dafür bekannt ist, seine Widersacher alle zu entleben und
er ihn im Fernsehen schon als Verräter bezeichnet hat.
Weißt du, wer auf der Liste ist, hat in der Regel nicht lange zu leben.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass jemand anderes ihm zuvor gekommen ist und dass
das jetzt quasi so eine günstige Sache ist,
aber mal ehrlich, Bombe in Russlands Airspace,
die so in so einem Privatflugzeug geplantet wird, also es fällt mir einfach
schwer, andere Theorien zu bevorzugen. Sagen wir es mal so.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es so wäre.
Gehen wir nur mal davon aus, dass es so wäre, was ist das für ein Signal?
Ja, also was auch noch plausibel oder möglich ist, ist, dass sozusagen jemand
Putin einfach einen Gefallen getan hat.
Dass Putin quasi nicht offiziell jetzt irgendjemandem einen Befehl oder eine Anweisung gegeben hat,
sondern nur aufgrund seiner Äußerungen, dass dann bestimmte Leute im Apparat
daraus einfach gefolgert haben,
ja, der Mann muss weg,
so, und Putin, Putin hat sich ja auch, ja, hat ja den den Angehörigen der Opfer sein.
Beileid ausgesprochen, öffentlich, so dieses Flugzeugabsturzes und ich weiß
nicht, ob ich da ein bisschen zu viel rein interpretiere, aber er sah zufrieden
aus, als er das erzählte.
Also jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass er da jetzt laut feixt, aber er schien auch
nicht allzu sehr betroffen zu sein, sondern er machte eher einen etwas entspannten
und ja, möglicherweise erfreuten Eindruck.
So, das war meine Interpretation, ich weiß nicht, hast du das gesehen,
sein Interview mit oder seine,
Seine Beileidserklärung.
Ich hab nicht das ganze Ding angeschaut, aber ich hab ein Foto von seinem Gesichtsausdruck
gesehen. Ich weiß schon was du meinst.
Unabhängig mal davon, das ist ja so ein bisschen Kaffeesatzleserei.
Ich sag einfach mal nur, gehen wir mal davon aus, es wäre so.
Und unter den Optionen, die du genannt hast, erscheint es mir die wahrscheinlichste zu sein.
Ja, 90 Prozent würde ich sagen. Zu 90 Prozent war es von Putin veranlasst.
Oder auch nur 70% irgendwie ist immer noch nennenswert.
Aber gehen wir mal einfach nur davon aus. Was bedeutet das dann?
Weil ich denke mal die Wahrnehmung, dass er es war, die ist ohnehin da.
Sowohl in der russischen Öffentlichkeit als auch bei uns. Also selbst wenn es
jetzt jemand anders gemacht hat, es ist für ihn recht schwierig ein Bild zu
projizieren, dass alle denken so, ach nee der war das bestimmt nicht.
Das muss er auch wissen sozusagen. Weil so etwas eigentlich nicht passieren
darf unter seiner Herrschaft, dass er dann auch nicht beteiligt ist.
Also es kann ja nicht einfach irgendwelche Eliten in ihren Privatflugzeugen sprengen.
Das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass dieser ganze Apparat schon nicht mehr funktioniert
und davor müsst ihr ja noch mehr Angst haben, als vor Briefe geschehen.
B. Ja, es ist aber tatsächlich auch,
gerade weil dieser Anschlag auch unschuldige Opfer gekostet hat und so sozusagen
so breit und und eher grob war,
ja wirft das kein gutes Bild natürlich auf Russland und Putin.
Also er war ein bisschen zu unelegant.
Genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus, also was hat das sozusagen
für Folgen. Und eine der Folgen ist halt, wenn, also davon ausgehen,
dass diese Wahrnehmung so ist und wir sehen das so, was heißt das?
Es heißt auf der einen Seite eben genau diese Skrupellosigkeit sowohl gegen die Eliten,
okay das ist nichts neues, da geht die normale Bevölkerung in Russland ohnehin
davon aus, dass die irgendwie alles unter sich ausmachen und sich auch gegenseitig
töten und so weiter und das ist ja auch nicht ihr Ding.
Was die Beteiligten sozusagen Zivilisten betrifft, das ist dann halt Kollateralschaden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das für großes Aufheben sorgt, es sei denn es handelt
sich dabei um besonders populäre, bekannte Personen, wovon ich jetzt nichts
mitbekommen hätte, dass dem so ist.
Die eigentliche Frage, die ich mir stelle ist, wie nimmt denn die Öffentlichkeit Prigogine wahr?
Und jetzt die Tatsache, dass Putin ihn gekillt hat.
Weil es war ja jetzt auch, also er ist jetzt sicherlich nicht derjenige gewesen,
der mit Pocken und Trompeten irgendwie die nächste Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen hätte,
auf jeden Fall, weil er super super populär ist, aber als er da in Rostov am
Don eingeritten ist mit seinen Truppen,
gab's schon ne Menge Leute, mögen ein paar Wagner Klaköre dabei gewesen sein,
Aber das war schon irgendwie offensichtlich, dass jetzt so die Bevölkerung auch
nicht komplett durchgedreht ist, weil da jetzt irgendein Typ mit Panzern auf
einmal in die Stadt einreitet.
Die wussten, wer er ist. Und er hat sich ja in den Wochen und Monaten zuvor
eben auch trefflich in die Medien reingearbeitet, weil er war der Anführer der
Truppen, die Bachmuth eingenommen haben.
Darüber wurde die ganze Zeit berichtet. Darauf waren sie dann alle stolz, als das geschehen ist.
Er war derjenige, der laufend mit diesen Videos auch Kritik geübt hat und damit
natürlich schon mal das Interesse bei Teilen der Bevölkerung geweckt hat.
Jemand der es wagt, Gerasimov, den Chef der Streitkräfte, den Verteidigungsminister
Scholgou und indirekt natürlich auch Putin so klar mit starken Worten in seinem
eigenen Videokanal zu kritisieren.
Das war natürlich schon mal was. Und für manche war das vielleicht in gewisser
Hinsicht auch eine Hoffnung.
So in dem Sinne von der ist zwar auch nur reich und scheiße,
aber der ist zumindest ein anderer Typ und nicht irgendwie dieser Putin und
warum denn nicht würde ich ja gerne mal unterstützen.
Und ich glaube das ist halt auch etwas, was noch dazu kommt,
warum Putin irgendwie loswerden wollte, weil diese latente Popularität ihn natürlich ...
Ihm natürlich zuwiderläuft sein Plan, als Alleinherrscher und Gotteskaiser und
Sonnenkönig dazustehen.
Bregoschin und zusammen mit Utkin waren natürlich so ganz klar Vertreter der
extremen Rechten in Russland.
Gehörten eher zu der Gruppe, die eigentlich den totalen Krieg wollte,
mehr Mobilisierung und einfach die Eskalation.
Insofern wurde ja auch gespottet, dass Putin jetzt endlich wirklich mal Nazis getötet hat.
Wo mit diesem Anschlag und ich meine bei Utkin kann man das glaube ich,
ja, kann man zweifelsfrei sagen, dass das ein absoluter Neonazi ist.
A. Das ist die Denazifizierung des russischen Luftraums.
Insofern ist zusammen auch jetzt generell mit anderem Vorgehen gegen diese rechte
Mill-Blogger-Szene, den, wie heißt der jetzt, den sie verhaftet haben.
Ja, aus Luhansk, der...
Gierkin. Gierkin, Gierkin, ja, genau, so, also zusammen mit halt auch der Verhaftung
von Gierkin und Vorgehen gegen andere russische Mailblogger ergibt sich so das Bild,
dass ja eine weitere Eskalation so im Moment von Putin auch nicht erwünscht ist,
so dass er lieber ja da ein bisschen den Deckel drauf hält und nicht irgendwie
zu sehr die Bevölkerung beunruhigen will.
Und auch wir rechnen damit, dass wenn es eine neue größere Mobilisierung geben
sollte, dass das wahrscheinlich erst nach der Wahl passieren wird im kommenden Jahr.
So, dass bis dahin auch Putin einfach die Bevölkerung nicht weiter beunruhigen
möchte und dass ihm dieses Eskalationsgerede einfach ein bisschen zu viel wurde.
Und dass er deswegen eben entgegengesteuert hat,
um den Konflikt nicht zu sehr jetzt auf russischer Seite zu eskalieren oder
man braucht einfach Zeit.
Aber Fakt ist, dass Russland in den letzten Jahren,
Einfach diesen Krieg immer noch nicht wirklich als Krieg betrachtet,
sondern es ist immer noch irgendwie so eine militärische Spezialoperation,
wenn auch wahrscheinlich die aufwendigste militärische Spezialoperation seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg einschließlich aller Kriege, an denen Russland beteiligt war.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz will Putin offensichtlich auch keine Unruhe im Land,
in dem dann intern zu drastische Maßnahmen ergriffen werden,
zumal ja die letzte Mobilisierung auch nur so minder gut gelaufen ist und man jetzt versucht,
das ein bisschen einzugrooven und ständig neue Leute einzuberufen,
aber nicht in zu großen Zahlen und langsam die Produktion hochzufahren und nicht
zu viele Engpässe bei der Versorgung der Zivilbevölkerung zu haben und so weiter.
Also sagen, Russland hat nicht wirklich auf Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt bisher
im großen Maßstab und will das auch nicht.
Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert jetzt mit Wagner und welche Auswirkungen
hat das natürlich auf Russland im Allgemeinen.
Was man ja nicht vergessen darf ist, Wagner als private Militärorganisation
hat ja nicht nur im Ukraine-Krieg eine Rolle gespielt, sondern tut ja schon
seit Jahren eine Menge auf dem ganzen Planeten.
Jetzt wollte der neue Machthaber auch den Botschafter der Franzosen rausschmeißen
etc. wogegen sich Frankreich wehrt.
Ich will nur sagen, da ist eine Menge außer Rand und Band.
Eine Menge zusätzliches Konfliktpotenzial.
Wagner spielt überall eine Rolle. Wagner ist so ein bisschen die Go-To-Söldnertruppe
geworden, um sozusagen Diktaturen und sonstige Putschisten an der Macht zu halten.
Das ist für die ganz praktisch, weil einerseits gibt es da ein klares Dienstleistungsverhältnis,
andererseits haben solche Truppen auch immer den Vorteil, Die sind einfach loyal
gegenüber dem, der bezahlt.
Das ist jetzt für so einen Putschisten, der keinen großen Rückhalt hat,
ganz praktisch, weil wenn du dich eben mit Leuten aus dem eigenen Land umgibst,
dann haben die halt alle wieder eigene Interessen und eigene Ansichten und Verwandte und all sowas.
Aber wenn du da so einen Rudel Russen hast oder sonst wie Söldner aus einem
russischen Trupp, naja dann ist das was anderes. Auf der anderen Seite beschützen
sie dort eben vor allem wichtige Ressourcen an die Russland-Randwelt.
Dieser ganze zentral afrikanische Bereich, der ist ja jetzt nicht auf einmal
besonders politisch geworden,
dort geht's um Ressourcen, dort geht's um,
oh Gott ich kann's gar nicht alles aufzählen, Uran und diverse andere wichtige
Stoffe, die dort eben in Minen und ähnlichen Produktionsstätten gewonnen werden
und in all dem steckt halt auch Wagner.
Und damit übernimmt Wagner quasi, oder übernahm zumindest Wagner durch diese
militärische Präsenz natürlich auch eine politische Aufgabe.
Und lustigerweise hat ja der Prigorchin genau das zwei Tage vor seinem Tod auch
nochmal in einem Video explizit bestätigt.
Weil man sah ihn ja in seinem letzten Video, dort irgendwo in Afrika,
genau wo lokalisiert wurde es glaube ich nicht, aber es muss dort in der Gegend
gewesen sein, Zentralafrika.
Oder was heißt zentral, also Südsahara, dieses Gebiet eben.
Wie er da rumstand und meinte so, ja wir haben ja Großes vor und hier und Wagner
und Afrika und überhaupt und wir werden dann doch für Russland,
ich weiß jetzt seine konkrete Formulierung nicht mehr, aber er hat klargemacht,
dass er sozusagen seinen Auftrag dort sieht, Wagnertruppen weiterhin anzuführen
und dann im Sinne Russlands für die Größe des Landes oder was auch immer zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Bedient nach wie vor diesen, oder bediente damals den pathetischen Grundton,
dass das ja alles irgendwie patriotische Pflicht wäre, die er da erfüllt.
Naja, und ähm, jetzt geschieht ja einiges.
Also, es macht gerade ganz den Eindruck, dass jetzt, nachdem dieser Enthauptungsschlag
stattgefunden hat, es jetzt auch sehr schnell geht.
Da fahren Bulldozer über die von Prigogine eingerichteten Friedhöfe mit Wagner-Söldern,
die jetzt bei Bachmuth und wo auch sonst noch gefallen sind,
ja da wird einfach alles abgeräumt, was Wagner ist, die Büros werden geschlossen und enteignet.
Ich denke es wird jetzt nicht mehr lange dauern, in wenigen Wochen ist sozusagen
von Wagner nichts mehr übrig, nichts mehr zu sehen.
Es wird dieses Unternehmen nicht geben, alle Söldner werden mehr oder weniger
in die Armee gezwungen oder zum Beitritt einer anderen privaten Militärgruppe.
Da gibt es ja noch ein paar andere, die auch in der Ukraine aktiv sind,
unter anderem Uwunda, Uwunda, auch eine die diesem Scheugu gehört,
also musst du dir das mal vorstellen, der Verteidigungsminister hat auch nochmal
selber eine Privatarmee, also Russland ist auf eine Art und Weise korrupt,
da müsste man nicht mal einen Film drüber machen.
Immer wenn du denkst, krasser geht's doch noch gar nicht, da waren ja die Nazis
nicht so einfallsreich.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist sozusagen die Gemengelage und das bedeutet natürlich auch,
dass Russland jetzt in irgendeiner Form aber auch entweder Wagner komplett durch
eine andere Militärorganisation ersetzt,
die sich entsprechend ordentlich verhält oder wenn die Einschätzung gekommen
ist, dass vielleicht solche privaten Militärorganisationen zu volatil sind und
zu schnell neue Kaiser machen, die auch noch Waffen haben und denen man auch
sehr viel Geld zahlen muss.
Ob denn das nicht sozusagen auch eine generelle Strategiewechsel einleiten könnte
der Russen, was ihre internationale Präsenz in Syrien und anderen Konfliktzonen betrifft.
Bei der Frage, wie viel bleibt von Wagner und müssen die alles neu aufbauen
oder können sie Teile der Strukturen auch übernehmen,
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Normalerweise, wenn es eine super hierarchische Organisation ist und sich das
ganze Know-how in Kontakte und so in wenigen Händen konzentriert,
dann ist das ganz, ganz schwer.
Und die andere Sache ist, dass natürlich die Wagner-Kämpfer,
also die sollen ja jetzt dann irgendwie auf ein Verteidigungsministerium irgendwie
vereidigt werden oder auf den russischen Staat dann und...
Da ist dann die Frage, wie viele
Wagner-Kämpfer dazu wirklich dann bereit sind, das tatsächlich zu tun.
Das kommt dann auch sehr darauf an, mit wie viel Fingerspitzengefühl und Geld
im Gepäck jetzt die Leute,
die das jetzt übernehmen sollen, dann auf die bisherigen Strukturen zugehen und.
Auf die bisherigen Söldner zugehen.
Also schwer zu sagen,
aber ich denke mal, dass auf jeden
Fall sie einen Teil davon werden retten können
jetzt aus russischer Sicht so also es
ist aber so Vakuum also
tendiert dazu gefüllt zu
werden irgendwie und von irgend wem und da ist offenbar Geld zu machen das heißt
da werden sich dann auch Leute finden die dann ja das versuchen werden so und
und letztlich sind es ja dann auch Verbindungen,
Kontakte, Know-how und das geht nicht vollständig verloren.
Also insofern leider so sehr ich es mir wünschen würde, dass das Wagner komplett
atomisiert wird und denke ich,
dass effektiv da Strukturen übrig bleiben werden und weitergeführt werden aber
noch unklar ist, durch wen.
Aber was man allerdings auch konstatieren kann, ist, dass die...
Private Military Companies, die nicht Wagner sind, jetzt es auch nicht geschafft
haben, allzu große Zahlen an Kämpfern oder Rekruten anzuwerben.
Zumindest hört man nichts davon, dass da irgendwer auch nur annähernd in die
Größenordnungen kommt, wie Wagner.
Und mein letztes interessante Ding ist natürlich so, Weißrussland ist ja in
dem Mix auch noch. Also ein Großteil der Kämpfer hängt ja auch noch in Weißrussland rum.
Und ja, also Also das Ganze hat noch ein bisschen auch Krisenpotenzial, glaube ich.
Aber ja, faktisch unmöglich vorherzusagen, was jetzt wirklich passiert, finde ich.
Also machen wir das auch nicht, sondern kommen wir vielleicht langsam zum Ende.
Ein, zwei Dinge kann man vielleicht noch ansprechen. Es gab ja auch noch diesen
NATO Summit vor einem Monat war das? Weiß gerade gar nicht mehr. Ja neulich.
Neulich, genau. Ich guck gleich nochmal.
Auf jeden Fall kamen dort eben alle NATO-Staaten zusammen und das offizielle
zentrale Thema war natürlich der potenzielle Beitritt Schwedens zur NATO,
der im Übrigen immer noch nicht erfolgt ist im Gegensatz zum Beitritt Finnlands,
der mittlerweile in den Büchern steht.
Schweden wiederum braucht noch die eine oder andere Unterschrift.
Wir hatten jetzt auch nochmal vor der Sendung geschaut, was jetzt eigentlich
der Stand der Dinge ist. Das ist ganz interessant, das lässt sich gar nicht
so ohne weiteres herausfinden.
Also zumindest ist es uns nicht so gelungen. Es sieht so aus,
dass halt dieser NATO-Gipfel am Ende eine Erklärung rausgegeben hat und sozusagen
die Schweden dann auch in der NATO begrüßt, sozusagen, jetzt kommt doch mal.
Es hing aber am Schluss noch an Ungarn.
Und das Parlament hat mittlerweile auch dafür gestimmt. Am Ende hängt es natürlich immer an Orbán.
Das kann jetzt auch einfach nur noch mal so eine Last-Minute-Verzögerungstaktik
sein, um sich irgendwie weiter unbeliebt zu machen. Das kann er ja ganz gut.
Ich wage jetzt mal keine Prognose, wann dieser offizielle Beitritt stattfinden soll,
aber eigentlich müsste es jetzt bald passieren, weil der türkische Widerstand
ist ja da gebrochen worden, keine Ahnung unter welchen Konzessionen und der
Rest sind eigentlich ja nur noch Formalien.
Warst du noch was zu Schweden zu sagen?
Ja, ich hatte den Eindruck, es ist umgekehrt.
Orbán hat gesagt, grundsätzlich ja, aber es ist im Parlament noch nicht darüber abgestimmt worden.
Das ist meines Wissens die Situation, was jetzt Schweden angeht in Ungarn.
Und das scheint bei Finnland auch so gewesen zu sein, dass Orbán da auch gesagt hat, ja ja, okay.
Und dann aber einfach ewig gewartet hat, bis das dann wirklich ins Parlament
gekommen ist zur Abstimmung.
Und es war dann auch Sommerpause oder könnte noch Sommerpause sein.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, naja, in der Sommerpause wird das jetzt nichts mehr
mit der Abstimmung, das ist mein letzter Stand.
Und dass es irgendwann aber zur Abstimmung kommt und dass, wenn es zur Abstimmung
kommt, es dann wahrscheinlich auch, ja, positiv beschieden wird.
Naja, genau.
Auf jeden Fall, das war der offizielle Talking Point. Und dann gab es noch den
inoffiziellen Talking Point, nämlich dieses, was wird der Ukraine für ein Angebot
gemacht bezüglich einer Mitgliedschaft in der NATO.
Und ich denke, dass niemand jetzt erwartet hat, dass irgendwie alle auf einmal
die Arme ausbreiten und sagen, ja, kommt zu uns, jetzt geht's los, hurra, hurra, hurra.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch die Ukraine nicht erwartet haben,
aber man hat so ein Signal erwartet.
Man hat so ein Aufzeigen einer Beitrittsperspektive, ja vielleicht auch eines
Zeitraums erwartet, der kam aber so nicht.
Ukraine hat halt nach wie vor Beobachterstatios, so wie eben Schweden.
Und natürlich kooperiert man mit der Ukraine auf breiter Front ohnehin jetzt durch diesen Krieg,
nur das Ding mit dem Beitritt, das ist etwas, was sich halt einfach die NATO,
kollektiv zumindest, nicht traut und offensichtlich aber auch viele wichtige
Kandidaten noch nicht richtig unterstützen.
Also zumindest habe ich auch nicht so den Eindruck, dass jetzt die USA dahinter
stand, so etwas durchzupuschen, weil ich glaube, dann hätte es eine ganz andere Worteußerung gegeben.
BK'IN DR.
MERKEL Ja, mein Eindruck ist aber, dass das eher auch eine verhandlungstaktische Frage ist,
dass man sich dort einfach keinen Vorteil gesehen hat, hat, so in der NATO,
sich dazu jetzt zu äußern.
Das würde ich mal so vermuten. Aber enttäuschend für die Ukraine war es natürlich schon.
Also da hat man auch mehr tun können.
Maschinenpolitik hat dort einfach agiert.
Meinst du eine maschinisierte Politik oder eine Politik, die sich nur um Maschinen dreht?
Naja, nein, eine mechanisierte Politik generell.
Auch Parteien sind einfach Politikmaschinen und es gibt dann den Begriff der
sogenannten Maschinenpolitik.
Und das ist halt quasi, ja, einfach, wenn man unabhängig von allzu viel vielleicht,
ethischen Grundsätzen einfach opportunistisch agiert und regiert und mechanisierte Politik macht.
Ja, jetzt ist natürlich nicht so, dass die NATO nicht auch etwas davon haben könnte.
Also ich denke, also abgesehen davon, dass ich persönlich denke,
dass natürlich die Ukraine selbstverständlich in die NATO aufgenommen werden
sollte, wird es ja eh so kommen.
Ja, am Ende wird wahrscheinlich kein Weg dran vorbeiführen,
aber man hat es jetzt nicht als nicht für opportun erachtet,
darüber sich jetzt zu äußern. Genau.
So, und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was ist sozusagen der Schaden davon, das jetzt nichts zu tun.
Gibt es einen Schaden oder gibt es einen potenziellen Schaden.
Also anders ausgedrückt,
was spricht denn dafür, ein solches Statement zu machen oder zumindest ein stärkeres
Statement abzugeben oder vielleicht auch eine Perspektive aufzuzeigen,
eine konkrete, die so nicht erfolgt ist.
Meiner Perspektive wäre es natürlich eine Stärkung auch der Unterstützung des
Westens in der Ukraine gewesen,
der, bin mir sicher, dass in der Ukraine auch neben einer echten Dankbarkeit
für die Unterstützung auch eine echte Skepsis dem Westen gegenüber steht.
Das ist ja dann sozusagen die andere Seite der Medaille. Was würde das denn dann bedeuten?
Das würde vielleicht bedeuten, dass die Ukraine sich umdreht und sagt,
okay, also ihr wollt uns nicht beschützen.
So, dann sagen wir erstmal Pech gehabt, weil wir sind übrigens gerade mittlerweile
das stärkste Militär in Europa und die einzigen die wissen wie Kämpfen wirklich funktioniert.
Also ich meine, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass auf die nächsten zehn Jahre,
vielleicht mit Ausnahme der Amerikaner, ist einfach die Ukraine sozusagen das
schärfste Schwert im europäischen Militärbaukasten.
Keiner wird auch nur ansatzweise an diese Preparedness und Ingenuität der Kriegsführung heranreichen.
Jetzt brauchen sie vielleicht viel Training, Unterstützung und so weiter und Waffenlieferung,
wenn dieser Krieg vorbei ist und er wird vorbei sein und es sind ein paar Jahre
vergangen und die Ukraine steht wieder auf eigenen Füßen,
dann wird sie eine formidable Militärindustrie aufbauen und wird mit Sicherheit
auch die Armee weiterhin in einem hochgradigen Zustand.
Erhalten und ausbauen.
BK'IN DR. MERKEL Ja, also keine Frage,
man will die Ukraine am Ende gerne in der NATO haben und nicht außerhalb der
NATO, aber das setzt halt voraus, dass der Territorialkonflikt irgendwie gelöst wird.
Klar, aber was ist denn die Alternative für die Ukraine, weil der Territorialkonflikt,
also sagen wir mal, ich gehe jetzt von einem Zeitraum, Russland ist aus dem
Land raus und die ursprünglichen Grenzen sind wieder hergestellt.
Wir können jetzt lange darüber formulieren wie lange das dauert,
ob das jemals passieren wird, aber ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, es wird passieren.
Es wird ein schmerzlicher Prozess sein, es wird vielleicht noch zwei Jahre dauern,
aber meiner Auffassung nach wird dieser Zustand irgendwann erreicht werden.
Also wenn dieser Zustand erreicht werden wird, so gehe ich davon aus,
wird das dann auch mit einem Beitritt relativ schnell gehen.
Aber es gibt auch durchaus Gründe, warum man sich darauf jetzt nicht festlegen möchte.
Okay gut das seh ich ja auch, man möchte sich derzeit nicht drauf festlegen,
aber ich habe ja jetzt mal in den Raum gestellt, was würde es denn bedeuten,
wenn sich die Position, sagen wir mal durch Ungarn oder durch die Türkei oder
welcher Querschläger auch immer noch da mit reinkommt,
Polen würde ich wahrscheinlich an der Stelle mal rausnehmen,
ich glaube, so scheiße die sind, den Weg gehen die nicht.
Und die baltischen Staaten schon gar nicht so, aber Ungarn ist definitiv so
ein Querel, die das noch ewig rausziegeln können. Und auch die Türkei,
wenn sie sich nicht ausreichend bezahlt fühlt.
Und keine Ahnung wer sonst noch umkippt.
Wenn das also die Position wäre und dieser Konflikt ist zu Ende,
dann gibt es für die Ukraine eigentlich nur eine einzige Option, nämlich Atomwaffen.
Da sagt die Ukraine, also wir haben ja gesehen, Angst habt ihr ja nur vor Atomwaffen
und die Russen irgendwie auch.
Aha, alles klar, Atomen kennen wir uns super aus, Ukraine hat da Erfahrung,
kriegen wir irgendwie auf die Kette. Und das kriegen die auch auf die Kette.
Und dann würden sie das halt anstreben.
Und das ist halt nicht im Interesse des Westens. Ist auch nicht im Interesse
des Ostens, also nicht im Interesse Russlands, aber das kann uns ja erstmal herzlich egal sein.
Aber das wäre sagen wir mal die Alternative und deswegen empfinde ich das sozusagen
als Fehler, dass man nicht hier noch mehr tut.
Kann ja sein, dass das noch kommt, aber perspektivisch denke ich mal,
sollte man da hier etwas mit offenen Armen an die Sache herantreten.
Na gut. Vielleicht wollen sie auch erstmal abwarten, wie das mit der EU läuft,
weil da ist der Prozess ja zumindest schon mal gestartet und wird in den nächsten Jahren weitergehen.
Man muss natürlich auch das Land liefern und entsprechende Erfolge zeigen,
insbesondere was so Korruptionsbekämpfungen betrifft, um dort auf europäische Standards zu kommen.
Nicht, dass die europäischen Standards jetzt besonders hoch sind,
wie man an Ungarn und Polen und auch sicherlich an vielen anderen Ländern immer
noch sehen kann, aber naja, das Problem kann auf jeden Fall auch noch größer
sein und das möchte man verhindern.
Und da sind ja auch die Maßnahmen von Zelensky durchaus sichtbar.
Jetzt gab es den Vorschlag Korruption zumindest zu Kriegszeiten sozusagen gleich
auf dem Level von Landesverrat zu bestrafen.
Das ist schon irgendwie eine ziemlich harte Nummer, weil das dann von so ein
paar Jahren und Geldstrafe hin zu bis zu lebenslänglicher Haft sich sozusagen
auf einmal erweitern würde.
Aber es ist noch nicht klar, ob das durchkommt. Aber dieser politische Wille,
an der Stelle zumindest bei ihm, scheint zu existieren.
Ich sehe die Sache so mit den Atomwaffen.
Ich meine, es gibt das Budapester Memorandum, wo die Ukraine über den Tisch
gezogen wurde, ihre Atomwaffen abgegeben hat, wozu es aber auch nicht wirklich eine Alternative gab.
Dort haben sich halt USA und Großbritannien und Russland damals als Garanten,
sagen die, territoriale Integrität der Ukraine zu garantieren.
Und da bin ich der Meinung, dass die USA und Großbritannien nicht genug getan
haben bisher um ihrer Garantieverpflichtung nachzukommen.
Meiner Meinung nach hätte diese Garantieverpflichtung eigentlich auch.
Aktive militärische Intervention bedeuten können, sollen oder müssen.
Die war allerdings, natürlich 2014 war es schwierig, weil irgendwie das ziemlich,
gerade die Krim, irgendwie ziemlich unblutig gefallen ist.
Da gab es nicht so richtig was zu kämpfen. Aber jetzt eigentlich meiner Meinung nach,
ja, wäre die Ukraine nicht in der Situation, wenn man damals,
sagen wir, die Atomwaffen nicht komplett abgenommen hätte.
Kommt im Austausch jetzt aber den Garantien nicht nach in vollem Umfang.
So, das ist meine Sicht auf die Dinge.
Weswegen ich auch sehe, dass Deutschland da nicht unbedingt jetzt eine Führungsrolle
übernehmen muss und voranschreiten muss, obwohl es natürlich auch in Deutschlands
Interesse wäre, das zu tun.
Aber da haben wir irgendwie offensichtlich auch nicht die Politiker und nicht die Profis für,
um irgendwie in so komplizierten internationalen Konflikten irgendwie,
ja, es ist auch eine Frage von Know-how und das ist einfach,
scheint in Deutschland nicht in ausreichendem Maße vorhanden zu sein.
Deswegen ja auch immer generell, ich kenne das von,
wenn wir große internationale Projekte haben,
hatten, wo irgendwo Kunde irgendwo im Ausland,
nahen Osten saß und dann noch wie asiatische Firmen beteiligt waren und europäische Firmen,
ist man immer zu irgendeiner englischen Bude gegangen, die den ganzen,
die ganze Vertrag- und Projektsteuerung und so gemacht haben, im privaten Bereich.
Und ähnlich ist es aber auch in diplomatischen Initiativen.
Entweder du hast irgendwie das Know-how und die Kontakte und weißt,
wie es läuft, oder du hast es nicht und dann kannst du halt nicht so effektiv
sein und Deutschland hat es halt nicht so oder nicht in ausreichendem Maße im
Vergleich jetzt den Engländern,
die allein aus historischen Gründen viel internationaler aufgestellt sind.
Oder zumindest sind die Leute, die diese Erfahrung haben, nicht in den entsprechenden
Stellen, um wirklich einen Unterschied zu machen oder nicht zugehört.
Aber England war, glaube ich, immer mehr so nach außen orientiert,
habe ich das Gefühl, UK, wie auch immer. Aber gut, das nur so als kurze Intermission.
Ich denke, wir sind auch so langsam am Ende. Vielleicht noch so ein paar Worte
zur Stimmung in Russland und zur wirtschaftlichen Situation,
bevor wir dann zum Ende kommen.
Weil das ist ja mal die zweite Sache, so wie Banks vs.
Tanks und man hatte sich ja anfangs viel versprochen von den ganzen Sanktionen
gegen Russland und dann hat sich aber die wirtschaftliche Situation scheinbar nicht,
also zu einem Zusammenbruch,
ist es definitiv nicht gekommen und wir sind auch noch davon entfernt, dass es dazu kommt.
Aber das war auch absehbar. Ich glaube, unsere Vorhersage war,
also bis Jahresende hat Moskau noch Geld.
Erst dann wird es langsam wirklich eng. So, also jetzt big, big picture eigentlich.
Und wir haben jetzt erste Anzeichen davon, dass das Geld nicht mehr so locker
sitzt. Da haben wir jetzt daran gesehen, dass Russland den Rubelkurs hat fallen lassen.
So muss man das sagen, weil sie den ja mehr oder weniger künstlich manipulieren
und hoch oder runter halten.
Und da haben sie sich offenbar entschieden, dass sie jetzt mit einem schlechteren
Obelkurs ja, eher Geld sparen.
Sowas natürlich Importe verteuert so, aber ich denke, das ist ein bisschen auch
Zeichen jetzt, dass das Geld langsam knapp wird, um den Kurs zu stützen.
Und so subjektive Eindrücke, also ich hatte neulich die Gelegenheit,
mit jemandem zu reden, der aus Russland stammt und auch noch eine Wohnung in
Moskau hat und regelmäßig dort ist.
Und so einfach gefragt, wie ist denn so die Stimmung einfach auf der Straße
und zwischen den Leuten?
Was ist dein Eindruck? Und ja, die Antwort war, also die Stimmung ist eher schlecht.
Die Leute sind wohl bedrückt.
So es ist keine Feierlaune, was halt daran liegt, vor allem dass ja viele Preise angezogen haben.
Interessanterweise auch, sagen die.
Preise für staatliche Leistungen, man denken auch sogar der Spritpreis ist gestiegen,
zwar nicht allzu viel, aber wenn man denken,
oh Gott, wenn, dann sollte Russland ja im Moment zumindest an Sprit irgendwie genug haben,
aber so in Rubel ist selbst da jetzt der Sprit Wirtpreise 10 Prozent angestiegen.
Immer noch niedrig nach westlichem Maßstab, aber wenn man es wiederum 1 zu 3
umrechnet, zahlen dann die Russen vom Einkommen her, ja so 1,60,
1,70 für den Liter Benzin, real ungefähr 60 Cent, wenn man jetzt zu aktuellen
Wechselkursen, aber für die Russen ist es
Das ist also eher ähnlich wie hier und man meinte auch, wenn man in der U-Bahn
sitzt und so, die Gesichter hätten sich da schon eher verändert.
So, wenn man in die Gesichter schaut, sieht man halt zumindest wenig Freude
oder Entspannung, sondern alle gut.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein russisches Ding irgendwie mit dem
Leiden, Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist die Stimmung nicht gut in Russland.
Also ein russisches Ding mit dem Leiden, was meinst du damit?
Naja, das sagen auch in der russischen Gesellschaft oder Kultur gilt halt Leiden
als etwas moralisch Positives.
Also wenn du leidest, dann bist du wert, es ist halt anerkennenswert, so zu leiden.
Deswegen trägt man halt ganz gerne auch das Leiden zur Schau,
weil es eben Brownie-Points gibt, wenn man halt leidet und das dann stoisch erträgt natürlich.
Und ja, es ist halt tatsächlich das Geld, das die Russen halt deutlich auch merken.
Die Gehälter und Löhne und Sozialleistungen und so sind nicht angestiegen,
aber die Preise für so ziemlich alles, sogar Wohnungen, also sogar die Mieten,
sind irgendwie angezogen,
und,
Und das prägt halt dann die Stimmung auch von Menschen, die an sich unpolitisch sind.
Und die Vorausschau, gut mit den Drohnenangriffen hat man sich wohl mittlerweile
daran gewöhnt in Moskau, wie gesagt auch das Leiden.
Und die sind ja subjektiv auch im Vergleich jetzt zu Ukraine,
wo das ganz andere Ausmaße hat.
So ist das ja noch vergleichsweise harmlos, was da in Russland passiert mit den Drohnenangriffen.
Ja und ich meine, wenn da was runterkommt, dann sind das ja meistens,
also die gewählten Ziele sind ja meistens offizielle Gebäude.
Da wurden dann alternativ halt große Hochhäuser getroffen mit Unternehmen,
also eher reiche Wirtschaftsbezirke.
Beziehungsweise eben die anderen Drohnen, die dann über die Wohnorten der Eliten
rübergingen, das betrifft natürlich die meisten Leute nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann auch gleich wiederum das Narrativ in den
Medien, dass ja sozusagen dieser ganze wirtschaftliche Untergang,
das ist ja jetzt sozusagen die böse Maßnahme des Westens, die versuchen irgendwie
Russland in die Knie zu zwingen.
Und da ist dann halt auch das Feindbild dann wiederum nicht weit.
Naja. Also ich denke es wird noch eine Weile dauern bis über den wirtschaftlichen Hebel was passiert,
weil noch ist das alles auch viel zu löcherig,
also viel zu viele Staaten machen damit jetzt gerade einen großen Gewinn,
in dem sie quasi Proxy für Importe sind, die nicht direkt nach Russland gehen dürfen.
Da muss man sich nur so die Exportstatistiken anschauen, die halt dann entsprechend
Korrekturen aufweisen, dass auf einmal das, was nach Russland ging,
vielleicht auf einmal in so benachbarte Länder geht. Nicht vollständig,
aber zumindest in deutlich gestiegenem Maße.
Und natürlich ist ja auch das Verhältnis zwischen China und Russland wichtig.
Weiterhin sehr unklar. Nicht, dass sie jetzt besondere Freunde sind,
aber China hat natürlich ein Interesse daran, dass Russland nicht kollabiert
und wird im Zweifelsfall eher dazu beitragen, dass die Russen wirtschaftlich
so stabil sind, dass sie nicht für China ein Problem werden.
Ja, wobei ja für China ist China einfach die Nummer eins so und so.
China hat vor allem chinesische Interessen allerdings im Blick.
Und wenn sie das Gefühl haben, irgendwas ist in ihrem Interesse so, dann machen sie das.
Und wenn sie das Gefühl haben, es ist nicht in ihrem Interesse,
dann lassen sie es ganz unabhängig davon, ob Russland das jetzt braucht oder nicht.
China fährt weiter so ein bisschen die Balance. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist wohl,
was man auch kaum mitkriegt, ist, dass gerade in den Gegenden,
wo da die Grenze zwischen China und Russland ist, wohl auch so viel ungeregelter
Austausch stattfindet.
Da wird so viel gehandelt und über die Grenze geschafft, was keinen Eingang
in irgendwelche offiziellen Statistiken findet.
Und es leben viele, viele Millionen Chinesen dort, auch nördlich der Grenze,
die da auch nicht unbedingt jetzt sich legal aufhalten.
Da herrscht wohl auch ziemliches Chaos weit im,
Osten.
An der Grenze und es gibt da deutlich mehr Austausch und auch mehr Vermischung.
So viele Familien, so russisch chinesische und so. Also da diffundiert wohl
Russland auch so ein bisschen mit China zusammen und ja.
Ja das ist eine riesige Miete. Naja, jetzt wollen wir hier nicht komplett einen
Völkerkundlichen Podcast draus machen, davon haben wir eigentlich nun wirklich
überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Ich würde sagen an der Stelle machen wir einfach mal einen Strich unter die
Sendung. Ich hoffe wir konnten euch so in die aktuelle Situation halbwegs zufriedenstellend schildern.
Ich würde mal zusammenfassend sagen, die Lage ist ernst, aber nicht hoffnungslos.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass wenn überhaupt jemand hier gerade den Takt vorgibt,
dann ist es doch die Ukraine.
Und es gibt durchaus eine Perspektive für zumindest ein militärisches Vorankommen,
was in diesem Jahr noch Ergebnisse erzielen kann.
Wie schnell das geht, ob es noch gestoppt wird,
wissen so einiges nicht, aber ich denke es ist ohnehin alternativlos hier nicht
der Ukraine alles Beste zu wünschen und zu hoffen,
dass die Situation sich weiter verbessert.
Auch in unserem Interesse.
Und im Moment sieht es aber eher so aus, als wenn der Krieg auch in ein drittes
Jahr hineingehen könnte und
tatsächlich Anzeichen für ein baldiges Ende sind gerade nicht in Sicht.
Mal schauen, also ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen,
er ist auf jeden Fall bis Februar beendet, aber es kann sehr wohl sein,
dass wir zumindest noch die eine oder andere tektonische Verschiebung hier sehen werden.
Es wird allerdings eine Weile dauern, Russland davon zu überzeugen,
dass es jetzt wirklich mal aufhören muss.
Das scheint mir die eigentliche Schwierigkeit zu sein, weil die ja im Leiden
sehr gut sind und noch so einige Rückschläge einfach einstecken werden,
ohne einzusehen, dass es diesen Krieg hätte eigentlich nie beginnen sollen.
Okay Leute, wir sagen Tschüss, vielen Dank fürs zuhören,
kommentiert ruhig fleißig, nicht um hier irgendeinen Algorithmus zu füttern,
sondern weil uns einfach interessiert, was ihr denkt über unsere Position und
was ihr noch an anderen Erkenntnissen habt und dann hören wir uns bald wieder,
wenn wir der Meinung sind, es ist wieder genug passiert und das kann manchmal
ganz schnell gehen. Also bis bald. Tschüss. Tschau.